Oh gosh...
Welcome back, Master!
Welcome back to Ghost Trek!
My guitar is next to the five kippins.
Thank you!
Hello, hello...
My voice is kind of icky today.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe I've been talking too much recently.
I'm so excited to finish the game!
Yippee!
Thanks for the 10 gifted Star Creators!
10 gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Not great for a VA heavy game.
That's okay.
I think we'll persevere.
I think so.
What else?
What was I going to say?
I don't remember.
I think...
Oh!
I was messing around with some stuff.
You might notice some differences.
Maybe they're not so obvious, though.
Maybe.
Spankin' time!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
I think my voice is all wacky because I...
I haven't really spoken today.
Hold on.
I'm quite unobservant.
It's okay.
I'm a gamer with OBS or...
No.
With me!
Did you cut your hair?
No.
It's still so flowy.
Did you get a new haircut?
No!
You're extra cute today.
You're higher up.
Oh, am I too high?
Let me...
There we are.
Zemir is extra cute today.
Okay.
Why...
Why both of you saying that?
Was this an orchestrated effort?
I don't appreciate it.
I don't appreciate this.
But what I do appreciate is beating the game!
Woohoo!
We're on...
Yeah...
Let's get right into it.
And we have...
Hold on.
I'm just gonna go to chapter select because I don't remember.
We're on chapter fifteen.
Fifteen...
Sixteen, seventeen...
We have four chapters left!
And then we'll break the game!
Yippee!
And I'm excited because last...
Night...
It ended on like a crazy...
Thank you!
I completed making the homemade memphis style BBQ sauce for my BBQ pulled pork complete with a side of homemade slaw.
How are you... how are you so competent?
How are you so competent?
I don't understand!
Mint is cute.
I'm overwhelmed by how cute Mint is today.
I can't handle it.
I can't handle you!
I can't handle this!
Okay, so... so... so...
Recap.
We...
Okay, recap.
Recap.
A lot happened.
We found out that the daughter that was kidnapped was not the minister's daughter.
Instead, it was Detective Jowd's daughter.
Camilla is Detective Jowd's daughter.
And that she built a contraption that is eerily similar to the one in that pigeon guy's junkyard basement.
And uh...
The same one that killed Lin before.
In blue guy voice.
Aww, cutie.
No!
I don't want to be him!
I don't want to hear his voice!
And...
Stop super chatting!
How...
What do you think about me?
Stop it!
Um, yeah, we hate that guy now.
We hate Shaggy now.
Um...
Um, because...
Uh...
Then we were told to get the music box.
Because the music box has the gun in it.
We get the music box.
And we figure out that the other guy was...
Died.
Because...
Missile...
Oh, Missile.
Missile died.
But Missile now has powers!
Missile has special powers.
Because of some sort of...
Meteorite, maybe?
Some...
Some strange meteorite...
Fell in the park.
And...
Killed the guy that was holding Lin hostage.
Oh...
Um...
And yeah...
Missile better...
Missile better survive this or I'm going to riot.
Um...
So continue.
But yeah, I believe that's everything that happened.
Anime nonsense.
Got it.
Yeah, the Temsik.
The Temsik...
Fell...
In the...
Park!
And...
Uh...
Became Temsik Park.
And that's why the guy...
Was trying to not...
Have people build in the park.
So Sara fell asleep before the last two streams.
So I'm forcing myself to stay awake.
No!
Don't force yourself!
Okay?
How does she...
No!
Um...
I have a...
Uh...
I plan on having a EU friendly stream.
At the end of this week.
On Friday.
So um...
You can...
Watch that!
Mm.
She's our kami-oshi-ghost mate.
Thank you!
But yeah...
Meteorite fell ten years ago though.
Which is still weird.
Weird.
Why is that weird?
Are meteorites on a timeline?
Are they on a deadline?
Oh yeah, and apparently... that's the biggest thing, you're right.
Apparently Sissel was the kidnapper in the park 10 years ago.
Which makes no sense.
There's so much that we have to learn about.
So let's... let's get to it!
Let's just jump right into it.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited about the game.
2.55 AM.
I would be passed out at this point.
That was a really wild twist.
10 years ago, a man named Sissel took a little girl named Lin hostage and then was killed by a meteorite fragment.
But!
Didn't Detective Jout say that the guy's name was not Sissel?
Thank you for yapping I got stuck in traffic.
I almost didn't make it so I'm hype.
Let's go, Saku!
Welcome home!
Nils, thank you for the bank!
No, no one has said that today.
I don't think anybody will say it today.
Anyway.
And then was killed by a meteorite fragment.
Mint.
Frag.
I killed a man!
Tonight, a man named Sissel met a detective named Lin at the park.
At a junkyard on the edge of town.
And then was killed by a bullet.
Oh!
One other thing I forgot to mention.
We forgot the manipulator.
There's like some other ghost man that is a manipulator.
It's not like a twin situation, is it?
Like, that'd be crazy.
Cooper!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
And...
Yeah, he...
Low battery.
Hold on.
Let me...
Oh, shoot.
I have a cord!
I'm sorry!
I got it!
Okay.
My controller is plugged in.
What was I saying?
What?
What's wrong?
Why are you guys doing the tehepero?
Nice save.
What do you mean liquid?
Oh, liquid and solid sisal?
I hope so.
Here's to our Oshis missel.
And Minto too!
Thank you!
My Oshi is also missel.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um...
Tonight, a man named Sissel met a detective named Lin at a junkyard on the edge of town and then was killed by a bullet.
And we think that maybe the manipulator...
Well, we don't think.
We think that the manipulator manipulated the gun to kill the mom instead of the contraption working as it was supposed to.
And then also that maybe we think that the manipulator possessed Lin to shoot Sissel.
Miso!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
And Smashboo, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Why are you guys gifting so many gifted memberships today?
Why is going on?
But the scene I was waiting for me on the other end of the phone line feels like the final nail in the coffin of my lost memory.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, and that's right!
Wait, what is going on?
Huh?
You're a pig.
What did I say?
What is this?
What?
YouTube chat story, people are talking about how cute Mint is.
Some people say that she is extra cute today, while others say that she is always cute.
I hate this!
Wait...
I see myself… Sissification maybe?
What is going on?
I'm going to pull picture the gifted.
I Primack, thanks for the gifted.
Niels, thanks for the 10 gifted.
C2, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Oh my gosh.
This is the peak.
Oh boy.
Okay, wait.
Also, because...
Also because...
Detective Carbonaro also betrayed us.
He said, you gotta kill Detective Jowd or something by tonight.
He said the deal still stands.
He betrayed us, I think.
What is going on?
Who are you?
Liquid!
There you are, Commander Sith.
Finally.
Huh?
Sissel?
What?
Where have you been, my good man?
We've been looking everywhere for you.
What?
Had a little unfinished business to take care of.
Didn't think it would take this long.
What about your people?
They sure went out of their way to mess me up.
Arigato, arigato.
How are there three of us?
Thanks for playing through one of my favorite games.
This is the first time I've watched a streamer play through an entire game from start to finish.
It's been kind of poggers.
I hope you enjoy the finale.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I say, I believe we fulfilled every one of your conditions in our little deal.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys!
Minto, minto.
Can you say purple burglar alarm?
Did I say something bad just now?
I don't know.
What right do you have to complain about anything outside our bargain?
It's a tongue twister.
Oh, okay.
We can talk about that when we get together.
This will be our last communication by telephone.
We'll arrive in one hour.
I look forward to seeing you, Cecil.
What?
How do you know me?
How, how do I, how am I know me?
How am I standing know me?
How am I there?
Dawn is approaching.
The darkness surrounding my own mystery is deep.
But I know it's always darkest before the dawn.
Did I convince myself I'm Cecil but I'm not actually Cecil?
Huh?
Solid.
Am I solid, Cecil?
Wait, that, no, that is not solid Cecil.
Hmm, yes.
We're nearing the final stages of our little deal, my good man.
Yes, sir.
All preparations are complete, sir.
And we just had a report, sir.
Lights have been spotted, sir.
Lights?
Have they now?
By all means, let me have a look.
My voice being raspy today is perfect for this guy.
Oh my gosh, we haven't seen these guys since the very beginning.
And we're on part five.
Always there, too there are.
A master and an apprentice.
Whoa.
That's a Star Wars reference, man.
Thanks for the clarification.
Aren't we actually right?
And has this been VR missions this whole time?
Hmm, yes.
We're very close.
We will now disconnect from the communication cable and have no service until we arrive, sir.
Wait, are they in like a spaceship?
What?
What do you mean?
Very well.
Huh?
Arrive where?
What is going on?
The lamp couldn't gaslight us?
That's what I feel like.
Wait, it's zooming out?
Oh my god, wait.
Are we really actually on?
No, we're underwater!
We're in a submarine.
What?
Nice try, Inspector Cabanela.
But you could never stop me.
Oh my god, he's got an evil look on his face.
Oh my god, what is going on?
He's pretty...
He's pretty alright.
See ya, sucker.
Oh my gosh, evil Cecil.
Solidus!
C'est ca?
Oh my god, wait.
Now we get to talk to Inspector.
So.
That submarine guy and his people have a deal going with me, do they?
If that's the case...
They probably aren't the ones...
Sorry.
The ones who killed me, right?
Anyway.
There's definitely something behind the Inspector's death.
I think I'd better talk to him.
I'm sorry.
Where did you get that information from?
Oh, he's unconscious.
Hey, do you think you could wake up for me?
Wake up!
Oh boy, still unconscious, eh?
Guess he hasn't been dead for very long, then.
See you later, alligator.
Thanks, Angel!
Thanks for the gift!
I'll just go ahead and go back to four minutes before his death.
I'm a little nervous about what I might see there, though.
But if that's where I'm going to find my answers...
Oh my gosh, I can't stop yawning!
I can't run away from it.
I may need to go get some tea or something.
Once the criminal gets the punishment he deserves, the hostage will go free.
Carry out the execution immediately and wait for our call.
Okay, this is what we saw.
That's a good boy.
Gee,
a hostage, sir, is a handy thing.
It gives me complete control over the top police inspector in the country.
So, Detective Cabanela isn't betraying us.
He's sad.
What's the matter?
Why do we have an accent all of a sudden?
All those broken bones, smartabit?
He broke his bones.
What's it like to feel pain?
Does it make you feel alive?
Wait, the sisal is dead?
Why are you doing this?
Now, is that any kind of question for a top inspector to ask?
Isn't it obvious?
Revenge, of course.
Oh, my God!
Revenge on all the people who stole my life away ten years ago.
Make me feel alive again.
So, he's...
Wait.
Is he possessing my body or...
So, wait.
We died.
I'm guessing.
I'm guessing we died and then the ghost possessed our body.
The manipulator.
Don't be ridiculous.
It was a meteorite that stole your life.
Or have you forgotten that?
Wait, but then that still doesn't explain ten years ago.
Wrong.
I was murdered by all of you.
Oh, my goodness, my throat.
Maybe he has multiple lives like a cat.
Oh, maybe.
Detective Jowd who chased me down and forced me into a coma.
Even though I was innocent.
Lynn, that girl who was right there where I was running.
We were blaming the child.
Lynn, she was just an innocent little girl playing in the park.
Don't push yourself.
I'll be okay.
No worries.
If that brat hadn't been there, I never would have thought of taking a hostage.
That's the most self-centered garbage I've ever heard.
And finally, you, Inspector Cabanela.
Me.
If you hadn't done what you did, I never would have pointed a gun at that kid.
Wait, what did he do?
This is a whole lot of victim blaming, Cecil.
You were so proud of your spotless record.
And my case was the one blot on it, wasn't it?
Only two people know the real truth.
Me and Detective Jowd.
I bet tonight's execution will be quite a relief to you, won't it?
One of the people who know about the stain on your record will disappear for good.
That's why you didn't help him escape from prison.
Objection!
That's the kind of guy you are!
I got nothing to say to you.
You'd never listen anyway.
You're a good kid.
Now then, Inspector.
Time to make a big red stain on your spotless white coat.
What the?
Oh my god, he's manipulating everything!
He's too powerful!
This was another condition of my ideal.
To wipe out everybody who knew about Temsec.
Wait, then what about the old man?
Revenge?
That's what I'm up to!
None of this makes any sense.
Hey, man.
He's alive!
Mind telling me what's going on?
Inspector Cabanela, he's awake!
My head is spinning, baby.
Am I to understand that Cabanela character who just got shot is me?
Uh, that's right.
And you're supposed to be the scoundrel there who just shot me?
Uh, I guess so?
But you couldn't be, could you?
Huh?
After all, the guy in the red suit just walked out the door, right?
So, who are you?
I don't know!
I guess I just have to face it.
I'm not that Sissel guy.
I'm somebody who's searching for himself.
Poor guy.
What do you mean low battery?
Uh-oh.
Is it not charging?
Oh, wait, one second.
Let me try this.
Oh, that doesn't work.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Let me try this.
Oh, wait.
Um...
Ah!
I'm trying to charge my controller.
I can't use the Joy-Cons.
No, I cannot do that.
Um...
Oh, shoot.
I mean, maybe.
Actually, let me see.
Uh...
No.
See, can you hear them?
Can you hear them?
I'm pressing the A button.
But it's not doing anything.
Why isn't it charging?
It's worked before.
Hold
on.
Let me try plugging it in again.
I'll try it in again.
I think I didn't have it plugged in all the way.
Or it wasn't plugged in all the way.
Okay, now we're good.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, we're good now.
We're good.
The light is on.
Okay.
And somebody is searching for himself.
Okay, here we go.
Shut up.
Shut up, everybody.
That's why I'm here.
To save you.
At the very least, you have information about that guy in red.
Information I need.
I'm not a clown!
Stop!
No!
I'm not a clown.
So you came on a rescue mission now, did you?
Nothing like the sound of that, baby.
Because there's a very important life here somewhere.
A life valuable to this nation.
I get it.
She's cute as a dog.
She's cute as ever but extra silly.
You're a silly.
Colonel!
Cecil, turn the game console off right now.
Were you manipulating my...
My controller?
Okay.
Do your thing, baby.
All right, four minutes before the death.
Okay, trick time.
So, are you a manipulator too?
Oh, he knows what a manipulator is.
Why do we not know anything then?
Why do we not know anything about like... you know... I think that's kind of odd, like...
Everyone else kind of regains a little bit of their memory, like... not a memory, but like... a little bit of knowledge.
But for us, we didn't even know what kidnapping was.
You know?
How does Inspector Cabanela know what a manipulator is and all that research and everything?
He didn't know his name, but he kept everything that he knew.
For us, we don't know anything.
My man even forgot how to read.
Yeah, we don't even know how to read!
We don't even know how to read!
There's something fishy.
Like... like it doesn't feel like we were human.
Is what I'm getting at.
I don't know.
No spoilers, no spoilers.
I'm just cooking.
I have ghost tricks.
Powers of the dead, yeah, but I can't control living creatures.
Anywho, I think you'd better be very careful.
That guy in red is a manipulator.
Naturally, he knows about powers like yours.
Wait, so if I... if I change something...
Is he gonna... if he realizes you're here, things might get a little sticky.
You're right.
I'd better be careful.
That's a good boy!
Hello, ghost yellow!
Hope you're doing well today.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thanks for the donut.
Hostage...
Okay, we've kind of gotten all this part.
Let's see, what can we...
Oh, look at him!
There's that something emanating from his body.
Is it really the sign of having special powers of the dead?
Okay...
Helmet...
Oh, we can get up to the book!
What is this?
The top of this bookshelf is lined with books.
This one is the top is balanced so precariously, it's a wonder if it doesn't fall off.
How did the old pigeon guy even reach up here?
And I wonder if he makes his pigeon fetch it for him.
The stink?
Nasty...
Okay...
What can we do with the helmet?
We can rock it?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I think he noticed us.
What's going on?
We've never seen the ghost world like this!
So you're here, are you?
He sensed my presence!
Uh-oh.
Me?
Wait a minute...
I noticed you.
You think you can stop me, do you?
Oh my god.
He's looking at me!
I don't know why you're wearing my face.
But you might as well give up now.
I control everything.
Damn it!
No!
It doesn't work!
Everything, including the life of this police inspector and what?
Wait!
Don't shoot!
Oh my god.
So we can't make any obvious movements.
That's crazy.
This other me knows the powers of the dead well!
Who wouldn't notice what you just did?
You were practically shouting, Look at me, baby!
It looks like it might be hard to save you under these circumstances.
I guess I can't use my powers right in front of him like that.
Okay.
Interesting.
I was curious what would happen if he noticed us.
So interesting.
Okay.
So cool!
Oh my god.
He looked straight at me.
It's kind of freaky.
I'm not saying I would do this.
But are we allowed to gift you weapons?
Like are we allowed to give you maybe a sword?
No.
As much as I would love to accept that, I don't think I can.
I'm going to Japan.
Um...
But also, if this is for Ofukai...
After Ofukai, I'm going to Japan.
So...
I would like the gifts to be smaller.
So that I can fit them in my suitcase.
Yeah.
There and back.
Oh my gosh.
That would be awesome to get a sword though.
That would be so cool.
Wait.
There's...
If I open this, will the same thing happen?
Or close it?
Oh!
Okay.
We got to wait for it to heat up.
I think.
And go...
What's the matter?
All those broken bones.
Smart a bit.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh!
Never mind.
Okay.
He didn't even give us time to...
Oh!
But now we're closer here.
Okay.
Perfect.
And...
Oh!
Wait.
Everything is destroyed.
What about a SOCOM?
I won it!
PSA.
Do not give weapons to the dangerous VTuber.
It's not for my safety.
It's for yours.
Look at this place.
The whole thing.
The whole contraption is destroyed.
Is the old man dead?
What in the world happened here?
I think I'm starting to remember.
Something bad happened here.
And now...
There's another death alliance.
Lying hidden here.
I knew it.
What?
Another death?
Didn't I tell you from the start?
Didn't I say there was a very important life valuable to the nation here?
He wasn't talking about himself.
I thought you were talking about you.
I'm just a crazy character in a white coat, baby.
Oh!
His little bird is sad.
Okay.
Come to think of it.
Where is that old pigeon guy?
Okay.
We don't have much time.
Move it down.
Or...
Oh!
Like that?
Exactly.
There he is!
Oh!
Little bird!
This is some kind of a device.
Very astute observation.
Sorry.
My memory isn't working.
Yeah.
Mine isn't working too well right now either.
But I do remember seeing somebody use this equipment though.
I got to open this thing.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm so sad.
It's too sad.
Okay.
Let's talk to the doctor.
Excuse me.
Are you awake?
Of course.
I never sleep during work hours.
Professor, do you recognize me?
There's only one crazy character in a white coat that I know of.
He hasn't lost his memory.
I'm sorry.
I'm not the type who likes losing things.
But never mind that.
Cabanela, this is quite a surprising guest you've brought with you.
Pretending like he didn't just blow up the place.
Oh shoot!
We're trying to hide the evidence.
Are you talking about me?
Well, this is a different guy.
And I'm his guest actually.
Said he came to rescue us.
Why is the bird there too?
The bird is always with him in spirit.
I'm sure he's in a bad mood.
Unlike you, my sharp friend, he still hasn't gotten his memory back.
Hmph.
Pitiful.
Ouch.
That hurts.
Anyway, now we'll be going back to four minutes before your death.
In order to change your fate, that is.
But aren't we already in the past, man?
But we can go back even further.
I've done it before.
I still don't see a path to saving Inspector Cabanela.
But if we go back further, maybe I'll find a lead.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
We're rewinding even further!
Going beyond!
Okay.
Ghost-ception.
What the?
How many times do I have to tell you, Professor?
This place is dangerous.
Don't be daft.
I can't leave now.
Wait, what is he doing with Cecil's body?
He's completely dead.
But just as I thought.
I'm getting a reading.
This is the source of his powers.
If I remove it...
He's not dead.
He's just not there.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
The true form of the manipulator isn't something you can detect.
It's a spirit.
Ridiculous.
Okay.
So you figured it all out, huh?
Dun-dun-dun-dun.
Hold on, I have a cool effect.
I have a cool effect for evil Cecil.
Cha!
You're a clever man, Inspector Cavanilla.
So it's really true.
Y-you're...
I wasted a lot of time tonight because of you, Inspector.
Spooky.
But it's all just like you said.
I died ten years ago.
This body is just a vessel.
A shell.
I control everything.
The shell.
People.
Just like I controlled the Justice Minister and Lynn.
Evil meant hot?
Wait a second.
So it's true.
You were manipulating my baby that time.
You made her shoot your shell.
But why?
Why would you do a thing like that?
...
To create conclusive evidence.
You know.
On that security tape.
Now she's a murderer, too.
She'll suffer just like Zhao did.
Go back.
I have to...
I have to do it for the character, you guys.
Now then, Professor.
But imagine, you guys.
Imagine.
I put on...
Wait.
Do I have it?
Oh, wait.
I don't think I'd be able to get it right now.
Dang it, I can't.
If I put on an eyepatch, I would be just like Raiden.
Evil Mint Kawaii.
I'm afraid it's time for you to die.
I don't have any grudge against you.
I'm even grateful to you.
Doctor.
Oh, yeah?
So why don't you let me live then?
I'll be leaving this country forever tonight.
But before I do...
I need to erase all evidence that these powers of mine exist.
Along with the contraption in this room.
Oh my god.
Wait.
The bomb.
This time the thing will work the way it isn't meant to.
It'll be all over.
Wait, but.
Why don't you just, like.
All you have to do is like, use your finger and go On the fire.
And then it's fixed?
Evil Mint.
Please come crawling out of my computer.
Ok.
Cupid won't turn this time.
He'll shoot his little arrow this way.
Professor, look out!
How did he know that there was a bomb there?
How did he survive that?
Dynamite, eh?
When the devil did he put that there?
That's what I'm saying!
He planned it all out tonight.
Having my baby shoot him.
Having his corpse disappear.
His corpse disappeared?
Wait, 10 years ago?
No.
Oh yeah, when we were sitting there, right?
That medical examiner, remember him?
He was a complete and utter impasse!
I... I said it!
I called it!
Guy is probably in cahoots with them!
I...
I called it!
I mean, maybe I was being a little judgmental.
But...
Um...
I don't know.
He said he was going to take the corpse back to the lab.
But he'd already made a deal...
But he also was acting kinda sussy, you know?
He already made a deal with the manipulator to meet him and give him the body back.
But I wasn't going to let that happen, baby.
You saw through their plan, eh?
I noticed right away the medical examiner didn't know the first thing about examining a body.
He was being weird!
I knew he was a fake, so I tracked him down and bought him off.
Oh my god, dang!
He's a... he's a triple-crosser!
Bought him off?
I had him smuggle the corpse to this room.
Oh...
I thought we could...
Find the source of his powers!
Of course, never in my wildest dreams did I think his abilities were powers of the dead.
Anyway, there isn't much time.
He's leaving the country before dawn.
That's why I have until dawn, probably.
And I'm gonna follow him, of course, after I save you two.
But something's been nagging at the back of my mind.
I remember what Ray said to me tonight.
He said that spirits cease to exist when the day breaks.
But if that's true...
How could a spirit from ten years ago still be here?
Mmm...
Cabanela is ocelot?
No!
The doctor is ocelot!
Except he's like...
So inconsequential.
Yeah, I think Ray was lying.
I think I mentioned that last stream too.
No time for thinking now, baby!
Action is the name of the game!
Work your magic and take us back.
Even further into the past.
Okay.
If only...
If only they had...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize.
I thought I pressed Cabanela's text.
He said stop the explosion.
Foolish of you to say, too.
If you stop the explosion, he'll just do me in some other way.
Fair enough.
Then jump in there and take care of that man in red, would you?
I repeat.
Easy enough for you to say.
And most likely impossible to boot.
That huge explosion didn't even make him bat an eye.
We gotta tie him up!
Well, what do you propo- propose then, professor?
Pray tell.
Your best bet is to save me during the explosion without him noticing.
How is that our best bet?
This puzzle is tough to figure out.
How...
What?
How is that our best bet?
Why don't we just tie him up and not let him touch anything?
Easy enough for you to say.
Sheesh.
What's with all these people?
Anywho.
Jump in there and do something.
Okay.
My guess is...
When the explosion happens, we open up the door and have him fall down.
Right?
So that way he wouldn't notice that...
That way he wouldn't notice that he doesn't die.
But I also can't move anywhere.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
Okay.
Fool!
What do you think you're doing?
Oh.
I just thought I'd try it out.
If you do, you're going to set the contraption in motion.
Just put the fire out.
Oh, yeah.
I just thought.
He just thought he'd blow me up is what he thought.
Oops.
That was my bad.
There aren't a whole lot of things I can use my tricks on in this room.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Why don't you just set the...
You can move the fire.
Fire away.
I need him to move back towards me.
Can you turn this way so I can't reach?
Oh.
Maybe here.
There we go.
Okay.
Do I have to wait?
No.
I feel like it has to be something else that I can do.
I'm going to see what happens if I go all the way until the end and drop him down.
Right?
Oh.
But he doesn't...
Stand.
Oh.
There.
Okay.
Now he does stand on the door.
Nice.
Time is passing.
What if I drop him?
Oh.
It's no use.
I can't.
Oh.
Could the fact the professor is standing on it have anything to do with it?
I may look small but I'm pretty heavy set.
He sounds so proud of that fact too.
This door.
Such a pain.
Too bad it doesn't open downward.
Sometimes life can be so hard.
Wouldn't you agree, professor?
Oh no.
That's why we're both dead.
The door that opens downward.
Eh?
The door that opens downward?
What is going on in here?
Oh.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Dum,
dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
As he perhaps may have already noticed, time is running out.
In -and -out, baby.
Sizzle?
Who is this?
I know that voice.
Hmm?
What's with that frail sounding call for help?
He's here somewhere.
Is it Ray?
The lamp?
Missile?
Oh, it's Missile!
A little guy that looks a little fragile but has strength that surprise you.
Well, he's asking you to find him.
And before he's carried away, no less.
But I'm almost out of time.
Should I look for him?
Okay.
Uh...
I can't reach!
Oh no!
Wait.
Um...
If I can stop this toy from spinning, I can halt the contraption, but that won't really solve anything.
There's a smart boy.
If you stop the explosion, he'll find another way to get me.
It would probably give away the fact that you're here, too.
So I have to rescue you without stopping the explosion.
Is that even possible?
That's what has to be done.
Deal with it!
Can I reach?
Ah!
I can't reach!
How do I...
Do I just look around?
Oh!
Cecil!
Here I am!
It's Cecil!
What are you doing there?
Do you really have to ask?
Seriously.
Are you really going there?
Uh...
No, that's okay.
Never mind.
Anyway, I need your powers.
Will you help me out?
Of course!
Okay.
Here!
Let me come join you!
Um...
Okay.
Very good.
Here I am, Cecil!
Wait, but I think I've lost enough...
I've lost too much time, I think.
Wait, no!
We just have to figure out before...
What?
As the explosion happens.
So...
We have to figure it out as the explosion happens.
Maybe things will flow in a new direction.
Even though that's not the case.
The flow of the sewer is a little bit stinky.
Fate has changed.
Kind of.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
YZR.
What are some things that are the same?
Measuring device...
Toolbox...
Motor...
Is there anything that's like the same shape?
Okay.
Hmm...
Thanks for the super chat!
The toy cake...
Is kind of similar to...
The tool...
Oh, you can't reach that floor though.
Um...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe...
No, no, no.
Maybe down here.
Oh, wait.
Actually, what about the rats?
Here, here, here.
Trash can lid...
Um...
Trash can?
What's this?
Wait, what's going on?
Those squeaky guys are making a fuss about something.
Sizzle...
My animal instincts are starting to surface!
If you mean you want to chase them, I think you have to be alive to do that.
Hmm...
There must be some kind of rat feast in that trash can.
Those things usually make a bigger commotion than that.
Bigger commotion, eh?
What does it...
What does that mean?
Oh!
Swap!
Okay, they're inside the feast.
What's in...
What's going on?
Oh, more rats are coming!
Uh...
What's going on?
Why are there so many rats?
Now that's what I'd call some proper commotion.
They're...
They're making that trash can dance.
Truth be told, I feel a bit like dancing now, myself.
Oh!
It's getting harder and harder to hold my...
Hold my wild instincts back!
What a dangerous bunch.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I have like no time!
Oh...
What's going on?
Trash can lid...
I don't know what I just did!
I don't...
Wait!
The trash can lid?
Oh no.
I thought the trash can lid and the tire could change.
No...
Eh!
Oh!
Switch!
What does that do?
I have a trash can lid here now.
I don't know what...
I don't know what else to do with it.
Cancel...
Now it's flat.
And we can switch it!
Wait.
We can switch the lid!
Oh!
With...
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I got it.
Okay.
But we have to wait until it explodes.
I think.
Oh my gosh.
That's so tricky.
Okay.
I think if it explodes, it's too late.
You have so much time.
Zero seconds.
Okay.
Switch!
Look out!
Oh!
There we go.
Okay!
Easy peasy.
Oh.
Cabanela's not dead though.
He's not dead.
Sorry.
Oh.
Sorry, little pigeon.
Oh my god.
Look at the...
Look at the position.
The legging.
As for you, Inspector.
I have a little job for you.
I can't move.
I think I have four or five broken bones.
I don't mind.
It will prevent me from manipulating you.
It might make it hurt a little bit when I move you though.
Quite a bit, actually.
Damn you!
Oh!
No!
He's so cute.
Oh!
She's alive.
First try.
Nice work.
Thank you!
I can't believe it.
You...
You lot actually pulled it off!
Sorry, Inspector Cabanela.
I couldn't do anything to help you.
And there I am.
A poor broken heap of arms and legs.
But it's okay.
But no matter.
I enjoyed the show.
The magic disappearing act.
That is...
Nothing like it, baby.
Yeah.
His name is Lovey Dovey.
No way.
He's so cute.
Do you guys mind if I have some... Pringles?
I'm kind of hungry.
I bought some Minecraft Pringles so I can get coins.
Except...
Thank you!
Kiss!
Good job, Minto.
With some help from the world's finest best doggo.
Oh, sorry.
The world's finest...
The world's best doggo!
Yes!
I haven't had Pringles in so long.
I got them because they had Minecraft on them.
You get three...
350 Minecoins.
Who wouldn't get them?
Unlike a normal magic trick, I'm the one that managed to vanish without a trace here.
Okay, nice.
You want some?
Say ah!
What do you do with Minecoins?
You can buy...
It's for the Bedrock version, not the Java version.
You can buy certain worlds.
They have a Jurassic Park world, you guys.
A Jurassic Park Minecraft world.
They have a Godzilla Minecraft world!
Godzilla!
You can fight as Godzilla.
And you fight like Mothra and stuff like that.
It's so awesome!
Yeah, they have a Mega Man X-World!
It's crazy!
I'm really upset.
Excuse me, Mr. Missile!
You really shouldn't be mean like that.
And what's this lively little creature?
Oh, this little doggy is the warrior who keeps Camilla safe.
Or he would be, if he was actually still full of life.
Wait a second.
I just realized, how are we going to go back to save Missile?
How does this not create a time paradox?
And we're...
How do we go back and save Missile?
Camilla...
Gods in heaven, what a terrible thing!
That poor little girl taken hostage!
It's a cruel twist of fate indeed.
Wait a minute!
Miss Camilla is... a hostage?
Yes, we're sorry little warrior.
Miss Camilla, a hostage!
Anyway, Inspector Cavanella.
It's time to save your life now.
But you couldn't get very far when you tried before, am I right?
I love Missile.
But this time it's different, right, Sissel?
That's right.
With us working together, it's a whole different situation.
We'll save the inspector in white, and then we'll go rescue Camilla.
Okay?
Okay.
Let's hurry up and get through this.
Gee, kids.
You're making me feel like an afterthought.
Apologize to Cavanella.
You're right.
I should.
I thought... I thought he betrayed us.
I thought he was a bad guy the whole time.
To be honest.
No, he was a good guy.
It's a good red herring.
It is, yeah.
Okay.
Let's get started.
Inspector Cavanella is upstairs.
So our first step is to get up there.
Sissel, I'll go up first and wait for you.
Wait.
Oh.
Can you help me out, mister?
Okay, lovey-dove.
So cute.
We need your help.
Carry this measuring device upstairs.
It has Mr. Ghost in it, so don't drop it.
Thank you, lovey-dove.
So close.
Just a little bit more.
Oh, wait.
I missed the... I missed the...
Sorry.
I missed the prompt.
Okay.
We're upstairs.
There you are, Sissel.
Sorry for the wait, Missile.
If you want to see the best death in the game, let the situation with Cavanella play out without doing anything.
Really?
Okay.
We'll do that.
Four minutes from now, the inspector will be killed by a gun.
You just jump in there and stop him from firing, would you?
There you go again with that stuff.
Besides, it doesn't make any sense.
If you stop him from firing, he'll just kill you some other way.
Wait a minute.
That sounds familiar.
Yep.
Same situation as mine.
Your best bet this time around is to allow him to shoot and then save Cavanella without him noticing.
Whew.
It's even worse than last time.
Anywho.
Jump in there and do something.
I'm ready to jump in, Sissel.
Oh wait.
So don't do anything?
So I'm just gonna watch?
I'm gonna eat my Pringles and watch?
Okay.
Time is passing.
Did you see that?
That bad Sissel turned around!
Do you have to call him that?
But yeah.
Maybe this is our chance to try and do some ghost tricks.
This is the only time he takes his eyes off of me too.
You have something to do?
Do it now!
Okay.
I don't think I will.
I think I'm gonna...
Objection!
Nothing to say to you.
Ooh!
Dang.
He ragdolls over there.
So crazy like.
Like he got no bones.
Sissel, right?
What are they saying?
I'm a little scared right now.
Why didn't he die?
Because he's already dead.
He died 10 years ago.
I knew full well he wouldn't die if I shot him.
And why did you go to the trouble of shooting him at all?
Time is almost up.
That's enough chit-chat.
But now the situation has changed slightly.
These last split seconds are our chance.
They are?
Okay.
Wait a second.
Oh, there's a motor.
Let's see.
What goes on?
This was... Oh, another condition.
Wipe out everybody that knows about...
He's going to shoot!
It's too late!
Again?
I'm going to get shot again?
No, wait!
Our chance is coming up!
The last split second, right?
Leave it to me!
Hello?
Would you look at that?
The bullet is hanging in mid-air between the gun and the inspector's forehead!
Now's our chance!
Wait...
I'm here in the bullet right now!
Let's swap this little thing with something else!
Wait, what?
It's our only hope.
It is?
Wait...
There's got to be something here with the same shape and direction as the bullet!
Hurry now!
Swap that hanging bullet with something else!
That's a bullet?
What?
What is the bullet even shape...
I can't even tell what the shape is!
I can't even tell!
What is it?
Is it with the hard hat?
Oh my god...
No way...
Is it going to work?
Oh!
That didn't go...
Oh my god!
We tried swapping what we could find but we just made things worse!
Not nice, kids!
Not nice at all!
You put a dent in my lovely...
Oh no!
I don't have a napkin!
Oh wait, maybe I do.
No, I don't have a napkin.
Guess we better search for something softer to swap with.
Okay.
From the beginning means from this beginning, right?
Not from the doctor's beginning.
Oh!
Oh wait!
I want to see what he says here.
You've got...
Oh!
You've got grit, little pigeon.
I'd better get up there before the little pigeon's strength gives out.
It's still waiting for me.
I'd better hurry.
Yeah.
Okay.
Give me...
Don't worry, everybody falls for that.
Give me one second.
I'm going to go wash my hands and get some more water.
Sorry for the intermission.
Mid...
Mid puzzle.
Give me one second.
I have no napkin and I have a dirty hand.
Okay.
I mean, I don't want to use my sleeves even though they cover my hands.
But, you know.
I
was out of hot water.
I couldn't get any more water at all.
Sorry.
I left for no reason.
I filled up my thing again.
So...
It's boiling now.
You don't have a kettle?
That's what I'm using.
Thanks for all the super chat.
Thank you, guys.
I actually got this puzzle wrong the first time because I didn't know what a bullet in flight was shaped like.
That's...
It's weird, right?
Okay.
Once it's fired, the bullet will be the key to the whole thing.
Use my powers.
Okay.
So...
Trick time.
We have to find something soft that is the shape of the helmet.
How do we get it over there, though?
That's literally it.
But we don't reach.
Hmm...
Oh, wait.
We can move through the step ladder.
Help me, step ladder.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
Um...
ZR.
Oh, I can't reach there either.
I'm so useless.
Wait.
I'm stuck here.
Uh?
Eh?
Huh?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
We have to wait for him to set it down.
That's right.
I remember.
Bang.
Okay.
Chance!
Oh...
Wait.
Ah...
He's gonna turn around.
Time is passing.
Swivel.
La, la, la.
Don't notice me.
Rock...
Wait.
If I rock it now, will he notice?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Okay.
What was that?
I think I made things worse.
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Oopsie.
Oh, wait.
Um...
No, because it would still launch the helmet.
It would still launch the helmet.
Like, it would still go...
Pew.
You know?
Because it would be in motion.
Oh.
That's right.
Ah...
How do I get over there, though?
Hmm...
How do I get over there?
I can't be as long as you...
Hmm...
Uh, uh.
What was that noise?
Ha ha ha ha.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Ah...
Oh...
Oh, it's closer.
It's closer.
I forgot that.
I forgot that that happened.
Wait, why is the music stopped?
Oh, that's why the music stopped!
Oh no!
Jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle!
Okay, now go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move!
Now, I think we should be able to do it.
I think.
Now we just wait, right?
Is Missile going to intercept again?
Oh, it looks like the book!
Oh, the shape!
Oh, you're right.
It's too flat.
Oh no!
Oh, okay.
I shouldn't have moved the helmet on the ground.
I should have kept it up there.
Okay, okay.
I get it now.
Okay, we'll reset.
Restart, restart.
Are you sure?
Don't reset?
Okay.
I'll try it.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
Even though my powers are nothing, I can do.
Swap the bullet with...
Sorry, inspector.
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Swap?
Hm?
Now it's just hanging there.
Oh, oh, I get it.
Okay, I didn't realize that it would like...
If I swapped it with the book, it would then slide down.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I get it now.
I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
So I still had to rock it to the ground.
Or like, rock it...
Knock it over!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
No worries, no worries.
Okay.
I get it.
The game spoiled her.
Yeah, pretty much.
It's all a waiting game for most of this, though.
So here we gotta wait.
We gotta wait.
La-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la.
Ba-bang!
Okay.
And from here, we go here.
We go here.
And we... Oh, no.
Just kidding.
We go here.
And we wait for him to turn around.
Objection!
Spin!
Chup!
And rock!
La-la-la-la-la.
What was that noise?
Nothing.
Nothing here.
Now I wait for him to get shot.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Yeah.
And I have to go really fast.
Pew!
Nice.
Just a hat.
Trick time.
Okay.
Oh!
Uh...
I need you to move.
Oh!
Go!
Okay.
Move!
Go!
Chup!
Rock it!
Jiggle!
Move it!
Okay.
Uh... Swap it!
Pop it!
Twist it!
Swap it!
Okay.
And then...
Oh.
Would you look at that!
Right on the hook!
I love knit hats.
So warm.
And most of all...
Soft.
Why are you in my head?
And now that I'm looking at it...
That hat is the same shape as the helmet that you just knocked down!
Aha!
I thought so!
Yes.
Now we'll intercept...
With the fuzzy hat.
Bing!
Da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh!
For some reason I was like...
Missile!
Okay.
Bullet with hat!
Swap!
Boom!
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's freaking dead!
Oh he just totally didn't think anything of it.
I don't think he noticed.
Looks like he pulled off another magic disappearing act.
And now I say again...
I love new hats.
So warm and most of all...
Soft.
Did I do alright?
You did a fine job little one.
Go Missile!
Wait.
You guys...
Did I do a good job?
Did...
Did Mint do a good job?
Good job!
Ear scratches for everyone.
Minto did great.
Yippee!
You saved another life.
And I'll keep doing it too.
Over and over.
Good job Mint.
Thank you!
Nah!
What I just...
What I saw in just these four minutes...
Gave me all the answers I've been looking for.
All our research these past ten years pales in comparison.
Right professor?
Yeah all I had to do was die.
So you two were working together.
That's about the size of a yeah.
Who would believe a story about a manipulator?
So we pursued it ourselves.
Just the two of us.
I wonder if the knit hat is a reference to Hobo Phoenix...
Hobo Hodo!
Maybe.
It is the same color.
If it had a little button on it then it for sure would be, right?
Or it would be the other way around.
Maybe Phoenix's hat is a reference to this, right?
Because this game came...
I'm assuming this game came out after... I mean before Apollo Justice, right?
Takumi didn't work on Hobo, right?
He didn't!
Oh.
Oh it was after.
This game was in 2009.
Oh.
I see, I see, I see.
Huh.
Takumi helped produce Apollo, I think.
I'm quite a crazy character myself after all.
Okay, let's hurry back!
Back to our time!
Nixie, thank you!
Fortunately I'm gonna have to miss the end of this game due to sleep.
But I hope you enjoy it.
It's only gonna get twistier.
Really?
From here, even twistier!
I'm excited.
Thank you!
I have to rescue Miss Camilla!
You're right, Missile.
And there's a certain guy I have to follow too.
Yeah, me.
Me!
I have to follow me!
Wake up.
Wake up, Inspector.
It was the performance of a lifetime.
After completing his revenge on Inspector Cavanella, the man in red left.
And now...
A new story is about to unfold.
And a new present.
We saved two people!
How are you feeling, you old crazy character?
What the ghost doing?
Hey there, Prof!
We're both alive, I see.
Yeah, nothing like it, baby.
But I don't know if I'm getting old or what.
I've got a few aches and pains here and there.
Used to be a little thing like an explosion...
Used to be a little thing like an explosion wouldn't bother me.
Yeah, right.
Like I'm going to believe that.
So what?
The guy in red is gone, eh?
Just in case, I posted special investigation units all around the building.
Let's just pray the boys came through for us.
What if they got me?
It paid off, though.
You can't trust anybody.
Not even yourself!
Apparently.
Damn it.
You've picked a bad time not to listen to me, buddy of mine.
Inspector Cabanela's so cool.
You got this.
Trick time.
Well, looks like both of their deaths were erased.
Unfortunately, in the case of the inspector in white, I can't call it a complete success.
I mean, how are you supposed to stop his bones being broken from an explosion?
But in any case, these two have the information I need to start tracking the manipulator.
I'd better talk to them.
Why do I want to talk to the bird?
How is Missile doing?
Alright, Sissel, it's time to go!
Out into the big wide world to rescue Miss Camilla!
Hold on a minute, Missile.
I have to talk to these two first.
Oh.
Okay.
I understand.
But just know one thing.
I go where the wind takes me.
Is this little doggy trying to put pressure on me?
Okay.
Let's talk.
Mr. Superintendent.
Do you mind if I talk to you for a minute?
I haven't always been a junkyard superintendent.
Intent...
Intendant.
Superintendent.
You know, I used to be part of the police.
The police, huh?
He's like a leaf in the wind.
Super Nintendo.
Not as a detective, but as a medical examiner.
I investigated victims cause of death.
Like mine?
Ten years ago, I was asked to autopsy a strange corpse.
Hit by a meteorite fragment and died instantly.
Well, what if the police report is wrong too?
What if everything is wrong?
There were no signs of life.
He was definitely dead.
But I never filed an autopsy report.
That's because the corpse suddenly vanished.
Leaving behind only one clue.
An unusual corpse.
I bet that's what I've been chasing all night.
Wouldn't it...
Wouldn't it be like...
So...
It would be bones.
It would just be bones.
We'd be a walking skeleton.
Could you tell me more?
Yeah, sure.
I have an interest in you recovering your memory and finding your true identity too.
Unusual corpse.
That's the only way I can describe it too.
It was an unusual corpse.
He was dead alright.
No question about that.
But there wasn't a scratch on him.
Not a scratch, but I thought he was hit by a meteorite fragment.
Spooky scary skeletons and shivers down your spine.
You gotta manipulate the blood flow and flow of nutrients.
I don't understand it any more than you do.
Okay...
It's aliens.
Aliens.
I was completely bewildered.
But when I tried to autopsy him I was even more puzzled.
I couldn't perform the autopsy.
It's like...
He's like manipulating the body but trying to be kind of like inconspicuous about it, so it's just like...
Or sorry, conspicuous about it.
So he's just like...
He'll like go in with the knife and the hand and he kind of shoots up like...
Maybe that's not very conspicuous at all actually.
Wait.
Is it inconspicuous or conspicuous?
Now I'm confused.
I don't know.
Wait.
Which one...
Inconspicuous equals subtle.
Subtle.
Okay, okay.
I switched them around.
I had it right the first time.
I'm confused too.
Okay.
Now I remember.
I thought I had it right.
You couldn't?
What do you mean?
The scalpel went in but I couldn't cut.
As soon as I tried to make an incision it would heal up in the very next instant.
That's how it went.
And no scarring or blood either.
The rock makes you immortal?
And I never had the chance to solve the mystery.
That's because the corpse up and vanished on us.
The morgue is very well guarded.
Nobody could have stolen that body.
But there is one way the corpse could have disappeared.
What's that?
If he just got up and walked out himself...
Nice.
He's bisexual!
Vamp.
He got up, opened the door, and walked out on its own.
Wait, is that on the security camera?
What?
He was dead, but he wasn't dead.
We saw it with our own eyes tonight.
Not even that explosion could kill him.
And he didn't even feel it when he slammed his fist onto that stove.
The corpse left behind some data from some...
The corpse left behind some data from some testing I did.
I got some readings for some kind of radiation...
coming off the body.
No wonder this town is so kooky!
They all have radiation poisoning!
No wonder everyone is so eccentric!
Oh my god!
Radiation...
Radioactive!
I used all kinds of instruments, but I couldn't determine exactly what kind of radiation it was.
Sub...
Sorry.
Un-discovered type.
From a world unknown.
Wait a minute...
Could it be?
That's right.
It was coming from that meteorite fragment.
Aliens!
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting super...
Outer Wilds vibes right now.
Just because I'm thinking of like the rock in Outer Wilds, you know?
And how it was so mysterious.
Ghosts of Matter.
Yeah!
No, I'm thinking of the one that...
When you turn around, it would disappear.
I went to that park and tested the spot where the meteorite fell.
Just as I expected, I detected radiation coming from that crater.
It was the exact same pattern of radiation as that of the corpse.
Yes, the quantum rock!
Yes, yes, yes.
At the time, I thought he was some kind of immortal being.
He would die only to come back to life.
I wanted to research it all in depth, so I quit my job as a police medical examiner.
Several years later, I came to learn the connection between my research...
I'm so sorry.
I keep yawning.
My research...
And the manipulator case.
Thanks to the arrival of this crazy character here...
Oh, stop now, professor.
Do you want to see me blush?
Cabanela's arrival.
Please continue.
I gotta get more water.
It was about a year ago, I say.
My neck hurts.
It doesn't hurt!
This man in white came dancing into my research lab here.
Minthe, are you the byproduct of radiation too?
Am I a freak?
I don't glow at night.
I don't glow in the dark.
Sometimes.
I don't know.
You are green?
Wait, I am a freak!
I'm a freaky ghost maid!
I think we should explore this later.
I heard there was an oddball here who's researching Temsik.
Is that you, baby?
I like how he calls everybody baby.
Even to the old man scientist.
Who are you to be calling anybody an oddball?
Maybe I came from outer space.
Uranium rod.
Maybe I'm actually an alien.
Mon, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Wow, what convinced you, Mon?
Did you think like, oh my gosh, she's an alien?
I love aliens!
You know?
Space ghost coast to coast!
The dots keep connecting, you guys.
This is kind of crazy.
The dots keep connecting!
I was investigating the manipulator case then.
And then I heard there was a man...
Who'd quit the police force to study the meteorite?
When I heard that, it was like a meteorite had struck me on the head.
Ah, look at all of them.
Oh my gosh, wait, I completely forgot about the guy on the left.
The guy who has his toes out.
At the time, we were just starting to get leads on this manipulator.
We didn't know who he was yet.
Space Minto!
But we knew he was communicating with a certain foreign country.
In one of those communications, we heard the manipulator say this.
The source of my power...
Is not of this world.
End transmission.
And that's when I put two and two together, baby.
The manipulator case and Temsik were somehow connected.
Which also explained how five years ago...
He used his powers to manipulate a birthday surprise.
A little girl made by her mother.
He added that gun to the contraption.
Most likely by controlling Camilla.
You're starting to freak me out.
What's wrong?
If I haven't started freaking you out from the beginning...
I'm not doing my job as a ghost well enough.
Honestly.
Alright, now we talk to...
Cabanela.
If I knew things were going to end up like this...
I would have tried to die in that explosion, baby.
That way I could have been dancing after Big Red by now.
I might be able to erase deaths.
But it's true I can't do much about injuries.
But really, you shouldn't talk that way.
Yeah, sorry.
I suppose you're right.
I just hate feeling so...
Helpless.
He was right there within my grasp.
I just missed the puzzle.
Sorry.
All our plans were resting on tonight.
And then this...
This had to happen.
Guess he's thinking about his spotless record.
It's not too late, Inspector.
We still have a chance.
Maybe I can catch him.
I say you're right.
That's not a bad idea.
I'll cooperate with you fully.
Go ahead and fire away with any questions you like, Mr. Ghost.
Okay.
I'm going to go get my water now.
And I'm actually going to get some caffeine too.
Because...
I know we're in...
It's going to be a long while to finish this.
So...
I got to be...
Not yawning every two seconds.
So...
I'm so sorry.
It's going to be a little...
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry for the second break.
I'm going to make a little note.
Getting water...
Getting...
Oh no.
I have hiccups.
No.
Getting water...
And...
Energy.
No!
Please, no.
Oh no, no, no, no.
I hate it.
Oh wait, actually...
Okay, I'll be right back.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
We are...
I'm back.
Oh my god.
I almost spilled my drink.
I have two drinks.
Okay.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I didn't want to leave two times.
But...
Um...
Yes.
I'm back.
Sorry, VOD watchers.
So sorry, everybody.
Are the hiccups gone?
Yeah, they're gone.
Yippee!
I don't know where to put the second drink.
I'll put it there.
Okay.
We kept the VOD watchers entertained.
We did?
What did you do?
You can see me scooting up in my chair.
Okay.
No, I can't see.
It's just for fun.
I'm a person who can't jump on this.
I'm a man who can't jump on anything.
A kiss.
Dive.
Now...
No.
No, I can't.
I can't.
Okay.
No, I can't.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
But what about when he said this?
Oh, that it was a lie?
Yeah, right.
I was murdered by all of you!
Detective Jowd who forced me into a corner.
Lynn, the girl who was playing in the park.
And finally you, Inspector Cabanela.
If you hadn't done what you did, I never would have pointed a gun at that kid.
Mmm...
Spill the beans, Cabanela.
Ten years ago on that day...
The Special Investigation Unit was working on a certain big case.
We hauled in a young man...
...An important witness to our investigation...
And then I did it.
I made two very stupid mistakes.
Oh...
Detective, I'm telling you!
I don't know anything about it!
Fine, fine.
You're under no obligation to talk, of course.
But if you don't, the Special Investigation Unit can make the rest of your life a living hell.
He's a witness!
If he's just a witness, why are you interrogating him like this?
The first mistake was being a big meanie.
But I...
I'd just been assigned to the Special Investigation Unit, you see.
They didn't share much info on big cases with a newbie like me yet.
And I wanted to impress them.
Good cop, bad cop?
Nooooo!
It was only supposed to be a simple matter of taking a statement.
But I was too green.
Me!
I'm green!
I'm a mix of blue, too.
I pushed him too hard.
I drove him into a corner and made him lose all hope.
That was my first mistake.
And then I made another mistake on top of that.
He was too minty.
It ain't easy being...
It ain't inty being minty.
Cabanela, got a minute?
The Chief wants to see you about your report.
Oh no, you left him in there!
Got it.
I'll be right there.
You stay right here and be a good boy now.
Oh my god, is that why he said good boy to Cabanela?
Oh my god!
He's been thinking about that for a long time!
And that's when I did it.
I left it behind in the interrogation room.
My gun!
Oh my god, you're so...
What?
How could you?
He used my gun to escape.
What he said is true.
If I hadn't made that mistake...
He never would have had a gun to point at Lin in the first place.
Fire this guy?
I know, right?
How is he not fired?
Manipulator.
We first found out about the manipulator's existence during a certain overseas communication.
Overseas communication?
For national security purposes, this country keeps tabs on the communications networks.
This particular communication was about making a deal with a certain foreign country.
Cecil, you said you'd stay put and be a good boy.
Oh my god, you guys.
I sometimes say that to Pies.
But I actually think I have to rename her Johnny.
Oh my god.
This morning...
I think I'm so tired because...
This morning was a little stressful for me.
And that I was just cleaning up so much shit.
I'm never...
I went down to pet her.
And I pet her.
She was looking out the window.
I pet her.
And my hand was wet.
And then...
And then I looked at her.
I was like, what?
And then I just saw poop all over her.
Poop everywhere!
And then she was like walking on the couch.
She was walking everywhere.
It's Johnny.
Have you taken her to the vet?
Well, I've changed her food a couple times.
So...
I know...
Like I've been...
It's...
When I got her...
I tried weaning her off the food that they gave me.
That she was used to.
But...
She...
Didn't...
She wouldn't eat it.
And so...
I started giving her a new food.
And then...
She had a bad tummy ache.
And I was like...
I can't pinpoint the problem.
Ugh.
I'm like...
Is she...
Is she like...
Has a sensitive stomach to something?
Or...
I had a shitty kitty.
It sucked.
Oh, I've never had...
She's not using the box.
No, she is.
She is.
It's just...
She poops liquid.
Well, sometimes.
Not always.
It's just...
It's been so bad.
It's been so stressful on me.
I'm just...
I'm just cleaning up poop all the time.
Ugh.
It's so bad.
Allergy?
I thought that might be the case.
So I've tried like...
You know, I was like...
Maybe...
The worst...
The worst of it was when she had chicken.
And so I thought maybe she can't have chicken.
And then I would try something else.
And then she would still be poopy.
Oh, man.
Everything is poop.
My God.
Thanks, Ocelot, for the super chat.
Anyway, sorry about that.
Why did I think about that?
Why did I think about my cat's poop?
It's okay.
Have you went to the vet to check their stomach?
Not yet!
Actually, I had to take Butaro to the emergency vet.
Like, literally a couple days ago.
I had to take him to the emergency vet.
It's just been... I'm like, oh my god, I've just been running back and forth to vets.
Over and over and over and over and over and over and over again.
I might have had a minor breakdown about it today.
When I was cleaning up shit.
So I think that's why I'm so tired.
Is he okay?
Yeah, he's okay.
He's fine.
He had a cold and he wasn't getting over it.
So I just had to get him some extra antibiotics.
So... yeah.
Anyway... anyway... okay.
Vet cost... oh my god.
I've probably...
Yeah, I don't even want to think about how much I've spent on...
Luckily, I'm in a position where I can afford it, right?
But... oh god.
But Butaro is doing much better now.
He got... he got his shots.
He got some antibiotic shots and stuff, so...
Yeah.
Survival of the fittest cats.
No!
Is YouTube finally paying you?
Oh my gosh, I got paid today!
Yes!
I got paid!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, no!
Thank you for the vodka soup, but please don't!
I feel like you have to...
Actually... I feel like I could have sent dozens of vodkas with the vodka.
When my cat was having seizures.
I know!
Oh, I know, I know!
Please!
No, don't send those.
Actually, like...
It's...
It's okay.
It's all good.
I don't need like extra or anything.
I'm all good.
Are you sure?
Yes, I'm 100%.
You guys already do so much as it is.
So...
Yeah...
Anyway...
This particular...
Let's get back to the game, right?
This particular communication was about making a deal with a certain foreign country.
Oh, he said he wanted them to buy him.
Whoa, you can see his outline.
Whoa!
It looks... Wait, can you guys see it?
An OBS?
I can see it.
It looks so cool.
You cannot stop me.
Stop!
Oh...
I think she's just, you know...
She's a kitten and...
It's growing pains, maybe.
You can't see him?
That's so weird.
Maybe if I... I'm gonna take a picture.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I can't take a picture.
It won't show up.
I don't think.
Oh, it does.
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Dang.
Never mind.
That's so weird.
Anyway...
He said he wanted them to buy him.
Him and his powers.
Buy him?
That's how we first heard about him.
Of course, we didn't know what he looked like at the time.
And in order to prove these powers of his, gave them two predictions.
He foresaw two completely preposterous impossible cases.
The case of a man who would sing national secrets during a live rock concert broadcast.
In the case of a man who would take the chief commissioner hostage in his own office.
Mmm, those two wonderful things.
Cool inmates at the special prison, eh?
Submarine that belongs to the other country in this deal.
Submarine!
But we haven't been able to find out where it's going to surface.
It's terrifying to think what would happen if his powers were to fall into their hands.
That means we just have to...
Wait, we can teleport back to the south and we can listen in on stuff.
I don't know.
If Blue Country has Blue Lady...
Doesn't seem so bad.
Right.
Highly unlikely they'd use him for peaceful purposes.
And now they have that little girl as a hostage.
Camilla...
We have to stop him before he leaves the country!
Sorry.
Spotless record.
A spotless record of yours.
Is it really that important to you?
Of course, baby.
In some ways it's more important to me than my life.
Than your life, eh?
Of course.
After all, it's because of my record that I'm able to get my hands on all intel as head of the Special Investigation Unit.
I'm moving to Blue Lady Country.
All in favor of moving to Blue Lady Country, say aye!
Aye!
Because of my position.
I get to direct all aspects of the investigation into the manipulator case.
What confuses me about this, though, is he knew all of this.
But still was going to allow Detective Jowd to be executed?
Oh, but I guess that would...
Because Detective Jowd confessed, right?
And he wanted the spotless record.
Never mind.
Consider Country with Blue Lady also have...
Blue Shaggy.
All in favor of killing Blue Shaggy, say aye!
Aye!
Oh, pick me, my lord, pick me!
Aye.
Yeah!
Aye!
No, not my Oshie.
Your Oshie killed a dog.
What are you talking about?
Your Oshie killed my Oshie.
The manipulator case?
That's why you cared about your record so much?
I mean, I'm not going to lie.
I think the manipulator case is a really big thing to care about.
Right?
Like, this guy is able to transcend time and space and people and dimensions.
I think that's a pretty big threat to international security.
Of course.
Why else, baby?
Yeah, it seems like a pretty big deal.
I just could never believe it, man.
Zhao shooting Alma.
I didn't care that he confessed.
There was definitely something more to the story.
Some secret.
I did everything I could to climb the ladder.
Everything in my power.
And then I finally found the answer.
It took five long years.
The manipulator.
He's going to prove that Zhao is innocent.
Yeah!
What incredible determination.
Oh.
Cabanela's determination.
Went after consulting with scientists.
You're not a byproduct.
Radiation.
But a...
Byproduct.
Electrolyte.
Am I a vampire too?
My god.
There's one thing I just don't understand.
If you were so determined to help Detective Zhao...
Why didn't you help him escape from prison?
Perfect record.
That's an easy one, baby.
Escaping from prison is a crime.
I wasn't about to help him commit a crime after spending five years trying to prove him innocent.
And he himself has to be executed, you know?
As a man of the law, I had to make sure that the execution was stopped legally.
That's why I brought him before the justice minister too.
I needed to buy as much time as I possibly could, baby.
Thank you, thank you.
You're welcome.
I think they're a little backed up.
Wrong forever, thank you.
You remember how this game used to be?
Haha, this guy is one step ahead, Tengo.
And this ghost leaves two times, but mint.
Now it's about revengeance and aliens and crazy plot twists?
Freaky.
So true.
I love this soundtrack so much.
It's so good.
But there's one little unfortunate result of all of this.
Lin completely misunderstood your intentions.
Ha!
What's a little misunderstanding?
My baby will come around.
Give it time.
But there are more important things to do with our time tonight.
Trauma is one of the best tracks?
Is that what this is called?
Trauma!
Thank you, thank you.
Chu!
I came back from a three mile walk with my dog.
All I hear is mint talking about liquid poop.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry, Kitty Funs.
Thank you.
Thank you, Hyper.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
So that contraption in the basement here, you built that to try and help Detective Jowd?
That's right.
Jowd and I worked together back when I was with the Force.
I used the reports of his case to try and recreate the device.
But there was just one part of it that I couldn't reproduce.
No matter how hard I tried.
What is it?
The cupid turning around?
RRR!
Thank you for the pink donut.
Thank you so much.
No super chats.
Got it.
Thank you.
Blue cheese!
Thanks for the thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Camilla told Jowd...
Oh my goodness.
Missile!
Blue lady is hot.
Shaggy?
Liquid poop is the best part.
No.
How do I say your name?
Is it Ian Tua or is it Lan Tua?
I can't tell if it's an L, lower case L or an upper case I.
My friend Bob Sacamano had a kitten and I visited him once and I was going to return some pants.
The cat shat right on your neck.
I'm sorry.
That's not funny.
You were going to return them.
That's so sad.
Kittens gonna kitten I guess.
I guess.
Camilla told Jowd it had something it shouldn't have.
Wait.
Told Jowd it did something it shouldn't have.
Made an impossible move.
Lan Tua like liquid.
Oh!
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
They said it's an L.
Thank you!
I added that part to the device I recreated.
I put in a part that would allow Cupid to rotate.
Otherwise the gun wouldn't fire.
So that must mean somebody manipulated Camilla's contraption.
As a result, we proved to ourselves that the manipulator actually existed.
Lin!
Inspector Cabanilla!
Hey baby.
Oh my god.
He's so awesome.
Sorry about that phone call.
I must have sounded like a real villain.
He's so smooth.
I know!
Oh my gosh.
I hate it to spoil your image of me.
Of that cool cat inspector you always looked up to.
Is that really the image she had of him?
Inspector Cabanilla.
I'm sorry.
I just heard.
You were chasing after that man all this time to try and help Detective Jowd.
This manipulator is such a dangerous character.
I was hoping you didn't have to be involved.
Ow.
I just bit my tongue.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
I will knock you off your feet as it will be.
No, it's not.
You're just a coward.
I'm sorry.
Me neither.
You are my last hope.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for everything you've done for me the last time.
I've been ripped for a while now.
Thanks, though.
Oh, Raiders!
Thank you!
Alien!
I couldn't catch the rest of it, but thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello.
If you've never played Ghost Trick, you're probably going to be kind of lost.
And if you plan on playing Ghost Trick...
This is spoilers, I think.
But thanks for the raiding!
Thank you!
Murphy, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
White on white text, I know.
Tonight...
Tonight, I'm going to die in your arms!
Wait.
I think I got it wrong.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Prunk for Robin, thanks for the 5 gifted!
I really thought we finally had him.
But my body...
My body gave out on me right at the critical moment.
It's like a cruel joke.
But a joke is a joke.
You might as well laugh.
Jowd!
The minister called off the execution order!
And while he was at it, he let Detective Jowd go free until tomorrow morning, too!
That's a pretty extreme, while he was at it.
The Chad is here.
With his massive chin.
Sorry, I took so long to get here.
Yeah, I kept you waiting, huh?
You can leave the rest to me.
There you go again.
You've always been like that.
You make everybody else run around, and then you swoop in at the last second.
Jowd.
He kept his coat!
Five years ago, you left this coat with me just before you turned yourself in.
I promise to give it back to you one day.
The pigeon!
Pigeon delivery!
What the?
He's still in his prison clothes.
He's in his little onesie.
I've been waiting so long, Detective Jowd!
We are so back!
Look how cool he looks.
I'm waiting for this day to come!
Thanks for not giving up on me, Lin.
Okay, I'm off then.
Good luck, my old friend.
Yeah, prison onesie!
Yeah!
Hypnosis!
Oh, this present you gave me.
It's just what I needed.
Thank you.
Glad you like it.
They don't even look at each other when they send each other off.
So cool.
Cecil, are you there?
Yeah, I'm here.
You and I have to go find that man.
I need your help.
Will you do this with me?
Sure, but how?
We don't know where the submarine is and the phone line doesn't...
Oh, the phone doesn't work.
That's news to me.
They use communication cables to make their...
Communication cables.
To make their calls.
The doges write themselves.
Sorry, I have my goggles on, you know?
You're hooked up somehow.
You'll see.
Could you wait here until we do?
Please?
Okay, fine.
I'm counting on you.
This true self you're looking for.
I bet you'll find it soon.
Alright, I'm leaving, Inspector Cabanela.
It's almost dawn.
I'm not who I thought I was.
I'm actually further from knowing who I am than ever.
But now I don't feel so alone.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, they didn't disconnect.
They're right.
Just got major...
Snoss-a-lott.
Snoss-a-lott vibes.
Why do you think I like Sissel and Inspector Cabanela?
Snoss-a-lott works though.
Snotticon?
Snotticon for these two is snoss-a-lott for Inspector Cabanela and Sissel.
I mistyped.
Each one of us, for his or her own reasons, is looking for the truth.
Together, I think we can shed light on these mysteries and drive away the darkness.
But it's almost dawn.
This was a long chapter.
Two hours.
Wow.
We're gonna...
We're gonna be in it tonight, you guys.
Maybe I should have started sooner.
This is my formal apology for thinking Cabanela is one of the blue guys last stream.
He's now just below missile and coolness.
I agree.
I agree, David.
We got a new background, but it's just black.
There's nothing...
Oh, wait!
I see what it is.
I think.
It's...
I think it's the sidebars.
Oh, neat!
Oh!
Ghost trick!
Langering death.
Did you guys like the thumbnail?
I even, like, manipulated my body so that...
So that it even matched the way the thumbnail looked.
Or the portrait in the game.
The submarine!
Cecil!
Okay, saving.
Manipulator?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I do have the ghost trick powers.
Continue playing.
GoIbD is for backseat in cats.
But I.B.D.
is sometimes as easy as...
For the...
To vet.
I.B.D.
worsens, not improves, for everyone with this issue.
I...
You know what?
I'm not gonna lie.
When I...
When I got her, I thought that, like, when she had her first pooping episode...
This is what I was like, I wonder if she has IBS.
I don't know what IBD is, but I'll look into it.
And don't apologize for trying to help.
I really appreciate it.
Your inflammatory bowel disease?
Is that it?
Irritable boob syndrome?
No!
Is she throwing up?
No, not at all.
No throwing up.
Oh, she threw up once.
The first time I got her, but I think that was because she was stressed.
Call it hot girl tummy problems.
All hot girls have IBS.
It's because God had to nerf them a little bit.
They had to have IBS because they're too hot.
I'd be shitting.
All hot girls have IBS.
I'm a hot girl.
Woo!
Sasaki syndrome.
And what do you know?
He's hot.
There has to be something wrong with you.
You can't just be hot and normal, okay?
What a nerf.
I don't have IBS.
Lin kept her promise about getting me hooked up about two hours before dawn the phone rang.
Two hours?
That's it?
Oh gosh.
Ring-a-ling-a-ling.
Ring-a...
Sorry.
I like almost hiccuped.
Hello?
This is Joud.
Sissel, are you listening?
We need your powers.
No time to talk.
We'll be waiting for you.
Okay.
Is that why Johnny's hot?
Yes.
Look at... What is this look on the doctor... What is this look on his face?
Look at his... What is this look on your face?
Are you looking at me?
Well, you better get going.
He's talking to me.
This long night is drawing to an end.
Yeah, looks like it.
Thank you for all your help tonight.
I'm the one who should be thanking you.
The bird bowed at me.
At the other end of the phone line.
I'm finally gonna find all my answers.
I'd better go.
Fourth wall break.
He looked directly at my soul.
I mean, I am a soul.
That's why I know.
So that's why you jeans-o-fiber-fiber- What are you talking about?
What are you talking about, Misfits?
A single telephone line connects me and the other sisal.
But that single line spreads out like a spider's web to ensnare the fates of many people.
How'd they get in?
When I just reached the center of the web.
Whoa.
Fiber-fiber-fiber-fiber-fiber.
Eat more fiber.
Welcome to the Yonoa.
Detective Joud.
Oh!
How did he get in here?
How did you get in here?
Did you swim here?
Detective!
My detective sense must have gotten rusty.
I didn't even sense your presence here in the dark.
He's just that good.
That's because I switched the power to my mask-off, Detective Joud.
I used your phone.
Hope you don't mind.
Beep-beep-beep-boop-boop-bam!
You think he slaps asses like that machine?
Hey, God!
Never thought you'd track us here.
Especially seeing as you are a death row inmate.
And I'm equally surprised about your choice of transportation.
A submarine, eh?
No, he's a gentleman.
But how did you find us, my man?
Not even the police knew where the Yonoa was going to surface.
Confounded?
Oh, it surfaced!
We detectives have a little saying.
If there's something you want to know about a case, ask the criminals.
What did he have?
Oh, who?
When did he...
The bullet the man in red was shot with had a radio transmitter in it!
What?
I have a little something for you.
And it's the pocket watch.
Is it actually like a...
Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
Oh my God, it's a Dragon Ball Scouter.
Oh my God!
Cabanela has given me some pretty weird presents in the past.
But they always prove useful.
This one was a radio receiver made to look like a pocket watch.
Birkenstall!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Hmm, yes.
Inspector Cabanela.
I hear he's an excellent investigator.
By the way, where is that man in red?
I know he's on this submarine somewhere.
That's an Ocelot move for real.
Ah, Cecil you mean?
I've been here the whole time.
Oh my God, that's so funny.
You can relax.
That's nothing but his shell.
YouTube dying tonight.
Uh-oh.
I hope everything's okay.
His shell, eh?
His spirit isn't here right now.
Most likely right about now.
He's controlling your daughter.
What?
Please, I beg you, let my daughter go!
If you need a hostage, take me!
Just please, let her go!
Bah!
There's something our nation needs.
Cecil has it.
That's all we care about, my man.
Nothing else matters.
However, it would appear...
Cecil has underestimated us.
He's left behind his precious bargaining chip here.
Bargaining chip?
Oh!
Us!
Oh, just kidding.
It's me!
I thought he was gonna go...
and like suck me down.
Our nation has already researched it.
This product that Cecil has to offer...
The meteor.
The source of his powers.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Slap!
Whoa!
That's a hunk of chunk!
Wowee!
It's ours now.
Or it's theirs, I guess.
What?
What in the world was that?
The Temsik Fragment.
It gives spirits special powers.
And now our deal with Cecil is concluded, as far as we're concerned.
What are you talking about?
What a mistake to make.
Right at the most crucial moment.
Now then, Detective Jowd.
Farewell.
Slap!
Oh!
Uh...
What?
What in the world?
The whole room just vanished!
Detective Jowd!
Where did he go?
Where?
Oh, because the table moved?
The telephone went down there?
Oh gosh.
What's going on?
Why is there a basketball?
What now?
I think I heard an explosion somewhere.
Oh, that means...
We'll probably have to switch things with, uh...
With...
Missile again.
In any case, Lin and the little lady should be here somewhere.
I smell danger.
I'd better find them.
And fast!
Trick time!
Who is this?
So you're here, huh?
It's Missile!
Yes, I think even I remember who you are by now.
It's Minto!
What do you suppose that shock was a minute ago?
I have no idea, of course!
I'm just a little sheltered apartment dog!
What, with my memory...
Loss of memory?
I can't say much...
I'm much better.
Anyway...
Let's hurry up and go save Miss Lin and Miss Camilla!
Do you think that trusty nose of yours can sniff them out?
It's Minto!
I'm sorry to say, I don't think it can!
Did I even bother to ask?
But you do have the power to swap objects.
So let's find that lady detective and that little lady together.
You got it!
Ring-a-ling!
Are those missiles?
I think, uh...
Are those missiles, Missile?
I'm gonna put mint on my shower speakers.
Have a nice shower!
The telephone is ringing.
Wow!
It's Miss Camilla!
I just know it!
My trusty nose is practically screaming it at me!
I think you'd call that more of a hunch.
Anyway, let's get to the phone before it stops ringing.
Those are torpedoes.
I guess you're right.
You bet!
Trick time!
Let's see...
Oh, that's where Missile is.
I can't reach anywhere else, so we're gonna...
We're gonna...
What is this?
Emergency light!
Can Missile... Oh!
Hello?
Miss Camilla!
Hello!
I don't think he can pick up the phone.
It's no use!
This black hello just doesn't like me!
What?
Just create a path for me, Missile!
I'll come right over!
Okay.
What do I need to switch?
No.
I could switch the emergency lights, but it doesn't really do much.
Maybe if I switch...
Oh!
Okay.
He's so cute, I know.
He's just this precious little guy.
And...
And switch!
Switcheroo!
There we go!
Oh!
Uh-oh!
I think I just heard another little explosion in the distance.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Cecil, look!
That black hello...
It came off the hook!
Uh-oh.
I better answer it fast!
Easy.
Hello?
Is anybody there?
It's her.
The little lady.
It's Cecil.
Where are you?
Somebody please answer!
I guess she can't hear my voice.
You too, huh?
Oh, good.
I thought she was ignoring me.
Somebody help me!
Lin...
Uh-oh.
It's been a while since Lin's died.
She said Lin!
Miss Lin!
We'd better hurry!
Let's go Cecil!
Go there!
It's been a real long time since Lin's died.
Oh, wait!
No!
She's not dead!
She...
Oh!
Wait a second.
Maybe she is dead.
Her body is not yellow though.
But she's kind of like...
I thought she was just like leaning over like the staircase.
But, um...
It's okay.
Uh-oh.
Are we gonna have to like Titanic our way out of here?
Oh, no.
It's no use.
Nobody is answering.
Oh...
Camilla...
Miss...
Miss Camilla!
And...
Miss...
Miss Lin!
Oh, poor Miss Lin!
Yeah, she can't seem to catch a break.
Looks like another tragedy has happened.
Oh!
Sorry to keep you waiting, little...
little lady.
Sissy!
I knew you'd come!
Miss Camilla!
And Missle, too!
I'm so glad to see you're all ri...
All right...
Well...
I wouldn't say I'm all right, exactly.
Hey, wait a minute.
Missle, your voice...
I think I remember hearing it somewhere before.
What?
My voice?
Hmm...
That's right.
Come on.
Miss Camilla has a core now, so that means she did hear Missle's voice before when he saved her that time.
So that was you, wasn't it, Missle?
You're the one who saved me in the park tonight.
Thank you, Miss Camilla.
I'm so glad I was born your little doggy!
Me, when I think about my Oshis, I'm so glad I was born to die to become a fan of you.
I love you, Miss Oshis!
Hey Miso, could you stay here and watch over your mistress for a while?
Huh?
But don't you need my powers?
I'll see what I can do on my own for a while.
After all, you're the only one who can protect her.
Okay, I'll do it!
I love Miso!
I wonder what happened this time.
I better talk to the little lady more.
I wonder if she got electrocuted from the water.
I better do something about the detective lady.
Oh, oh, uh, turn it?
Okay.
Lynn!
I'm happy you died to become my Yoshi.
Did you have to censor it because YouTube?
I appreciate it.
I'm glad I died too then.
Oh, Cecil, you're here!
Lynn, what in the world happened here?
I don't know.
Huh?
I just sort of blacked out all of a sudden.
Next thing I know, I was dead!
Yeah, I guess you wouldn't know in that case, you guys.
I think I have to go to the little ghosty's room.
I think I have to go to the ghosty's room.
I can't believe in the two and a half hours I've left the stream three times.
That's insane.
That never happens.
I won't allow you.
Please!
I prefer you dead ghost.
That's because I have two drinks.
Okay, you can listen to this bopping soundtrack and I'll be right back.
I'm sorry, I just have to pee!
I have to expel the ectoplasm.
Actually, that's not a good way to say that.
You know what?
Oh my god, when I opened the door...
When I opened the door to leave...
Pies came like running at me and she was like...
She kept chirping at me.
And then she was following me.
And I fed her.
I fed her when I went to go get the water earlier.
So...
So I know she wasn't hungry.
I think she was like...
Lethargic all day.
Or it's like she slept all day.
Because I had to give her a bath earlier.
And I think it made her really tired.
I had to give her a bath earlier.
From the poop.
And...
She slept all day.
She was just sad about it.
And now she's all like happy.
She even followed me into the bathroom.
One thing I really love about her.
One thing that I think is the cutest thing about her.
She's a plopper.
Like...
She doesn't just like lay down normally.
She just like...
She goes like...
She's so cute.
So like...
She even followed me into the bathroom.
And was just like...
La la la.
Hello.
Hello mom.
And then she just plopped on the ground.
She's so cute.
Does she spread out?
Yes she does.
She bananas.
She turns into a banana.
She's a plopper in more ways than one.
I hate that.
I hate that so much.
She's really sweet.
I really love her.
I do.
I hope she's okay.
It stresses me out.
Me wondering if she's...
Good, you know?
What?
How did I...
There we go.
Okay, let's get back to the game.
Let's get back to the game.
Bye bye.
Yeah, I guess you wouldn't know in that case.
I don't know what we're talking about.
Oh, about how she died.
That's right.
And where's Detective Jowd?
Is he all right?
I don't know.
Huh?
The room he was in just disappeared all of a sudden.
Rabbits do that too.
It's so cute.
Yeah.
Oh.
Now it's all making even less sense than before.
Give me one second.
Let me check something on my phone.
What is...
Wait.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
I'm good.
Everything okay?
Yep.
All good.
After we left the super's office, we followed after the man in red.
We tracked him with that radio transmitter.
Trans...
Transmister?
Transmitter Inspector Calvinella fired into him with the bullet.
The man in red took a boat out to sea from a small harbor on the edge of town.
Detective Jowd and I managed to secretly stow away on his boat.
And then we sneaked onto the submarine with him when it surfaced.
Before long, the submarine dove back down again.
Oh.
So that's how...
I was like...
How did you...
Okay.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the explanation of how he got down there under the water.
Under the sea.
Detective Jowd and I decided to split up.
He would take care of the telephone line and I would look for Camilla.
I found Camilla hiding here.
In the engine room.
She had escaped and run away here.
Wow.
That's quite an adventure.
What happened next?
I don't know.
Huh?
There was a flash of white all of a sudden.
Next thing I know, I was dead.
Okay.
She definitely got electrocuted, I think.
Oh, boy.
It sounds like it'd be quicker for me to see for myself.
Time to rewind.
Maybe from the water.
Es...
Yo, Noah.
Aw.
Camilla, are you okay?
Wow.
Oh, my God.
Cam...
Camilla?
Oh, no.
She's getting manipulated.
Hello, Lynn.
Or is it Detective now?
It's been 10 years since we last met.
Are you...
Are you really that man from the park 10 years ago?
I'm sorry.
Well, well.
I see there's no need to introduce myself.
Give Camilla back.
She has nothing to do with any of this.
Afraid I can't do that.
This is my last chance.
Look at the sass.
The hand on the hip.
The phone is ringing.
It's not for me.
Nobody ever calls the dead.
Yo.
Single-handedly.
Oh, my God.
The fact that you're here means that my revenge plan has failed.
Revenge plan?
It didn't happen tonight, did it?
His execution.
Well, knowing him, I half expected as much.
That's why I was waiting here like this.
Waiting for him to show up.
Ta-da.
Wouldn't it be just what he wanted?
To be executed?
Executed by his own daughter?
I heard about 10 years ago.
Oh, wait, wait.
I feel sorry about what happened to you.
But revenge?
Nobody could possibly know what I've...
What in the world?
An explosion?
Uh-oh.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Have I been had?
Look out!
Revenge, huh?
That's a feeling I just can't understand.
Of course not.
You're not him.
She's right.
I'm not him, am I?
He was going to shoot Detective Jowd.
That's Camilla.
When he came to rescue her.
It's just too horrible.
Anyway.
Let's bring you back to life.
Again.
He didn't have to add the again part.
Hmm.
Okay.
How do we stop this?
How?
Trick time.
How do we stop this?
So, let's see.
The cause of death this time...
was the mysterious explosion.
You're pretty up.
For a dead woman.
You know how detectives love a good mystery.
It's like a shot of vitamins.
And what do you mean for a dead woman?
Do you guys think that I'm energetic for being so dead?
I guess we should look for a way to stop that explosion.
Okay.
Let's do this thing.
Finding clues is like a dose of minerals to a detective.
Quite.
Very.
Yeah.
Woohoo!
You're quite lively.
I'm afraid with my memory loss, I have no idea what vitamins are minerals.
Rocks, fossils, rocks, fossils, rocks, and minerals.
Are you okay?
Let's see.
What do we have?
Oh.
Oh, yes.
This whole...
This whole scenario.
Let's see.
Oh.
I can't get to anywhere.
I am trapped.
We have to wait for her to move the gun.
I think...
Yeah.
We still can't do anything.
Wait.
Can I switch to...
No.
I can't switch to...
But also...
If I can't switch to...
I wouldn't...
I wouldn't be able to switch things anyway, I think.
Because...
The ghost...
Cecil would notice.
No one calls for the dead.
Oh.
And...
Here we go.
Trick time.
Wait.
But who's calling?
I can't get the line to work.
That's funny.
I thought I could use the phone in the past if somebody was calling.
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
The receiver has to be off the hook first, silly.
Oh.
Well, don't look at me.
I can't do it.
I don't have time.
I don't have any hands or feet right now.
Somebody, please answer the phone.
If you want something done, you have to do it yourself.
Okay.
Let's go up here.
This is an emergency light.
What's...
What does turning this do?
Uh-huh.
This is the phone.
Oh.
What about turning this too?
Let's see.
Let's turn this.
Turn.
Oh.
That's what that did.
Hey, we somehow managed to knock down the receiver.
That...
I'm kind of concerned about the condition of this submarine.
Somehow managed?
Who's to say that's not how I planned it?
Come on.
Hurry.
Now's your chance to get on the phone.
It might be Detective Jowd.
She's right.
I'd better check it out.
Using the new episode of the podcast to power me through...
finding a different job.
Funny that a ghost is helping me quit the job a woods gnome encouraged me to pass the interview for.
I mean...
Um...
You know what?
I think the woods gnome probably didn't know what they were talking about.
And you know what?
Just like I came back, there were changes.
You have...
You can do changes too.
You know?
Yeah.
Quit your job.
And I'll encourage you for the next one.
Hello.
Anybody there?
If anybody's still there, get yourself here on the double.
We're about to head out.
Speak up.
Why don't you answer?
Anyway.
Come on.
If you're coming.
We're leaving.
Oh.
I guess I have to go.
I guess I better go there because they're leaving.
Get gnomed, silly.
So I have to delay them leaving because that's the explosion.
So it might be true what they say.
That there are restless ghosts on board.
Whoa.
Creepy.
Okay.
We're back here.
That does it.
I promise to turn over a new leaf, mom.
Wait.
Don't leave.
Who is he calling restless ghosts?
Yeah.
Who is he calling restless...
Who is he calling restless ghosts?
Well, it's true neither of us is really resting in peace.
Anyway.
Looks like the sub just lost one of its crew.
I guess that means the fate of this sub has changed slightly.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
Sizzle has underestimated us.
He's left behind his precious bargaining chip here.
Okay.
This is when they take the stone.
There goes the phone.
Detective Jowd.
What's going on there?
I saw this little deal go down once before.
Just a moment.
The man in red is about to get his Temsik fragment taken away.
Okay.
So...
Do I have to go up there?
What's happening?
They decided to conclude the deal without the other party present.
They're just going to go ahead and steal the Temsik fragment.
But that's...
That's cheating!
I think we have more important things to think about right now.
Where is the Temsik fragment going to go?
True.
If I open this...
Boink.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
Open.
And go.
Now.
Oh.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
I'm going to be stuck though.
What's this valve do?
Beep.
Oh.
There it goes.
And up.
Is it easy?
Oh my god.
Why are there so many men in the submarine?
The Temsik fragment.
The objective has been achieved.
Now we detach the control room as planned.
Yes, sir.
Farewell, sir.
Yeah.
It's like a clown car for real.
Clown sub.
Cecil, what just happened?
Oh.
The whole room just disappeared with Detective Joud in it.
Don't worry, Lin.
I bet Detective Joud can take care of himself.
The main thing right now is rescuing you and the little lady.
I can't believe this is happening.
Now then, I'd better hurry along before Cecil discovers what he's lost and comes after me.
The Yanoa will be his coffin.
Oh.
May it lie buried here in the deep sea.
Forever.
Farewell, Cecil.
There he goes.
Oh, and that's why the water starts to rise too.
I think.
These poor guys.
Oh.
There he goes.
Taking off.
Hmm.
Oh.
So that's the cause of death.
I think we probably gotta get the little handle thing down there, right?
What is?
Don't tell me that's another thing you've forgotten.
The torpedo!
It's like...
Well, you've heard of a missile before, haven't you?
Yeah, the dog.
But a different missile comes more readily to mind.
It looks like he plans to sink the submarine with that thing.
I mean, all you have to do is just not let it rise to the surface.
All you have to do is just let it...
sit at the bottom.
Right?
This is not good.
We have to do something before that torpedo is fired.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Uh...
Lower!
It won't budge.
Maybe it's broken.
Oh, well.
I guess I don't have to lower it right now.
And even if I had to move it, I could probably get Lynn to do it for me.
Oh.
What are you talking about?
What about this one?
Nothing's happening.
You done goofed?
Uh-oh.
Sure seems like it should do something.
Maybe it's just some kind of ornament.
Uh...
We can't let it launch!
I think it's launched.
I think it's launched!
What can we do?
Let's just get to the torpedo as fast as we can.
Maybe we can find a way to stop it somehow.
Somehow?
A true detective never gives up.
Well, we certainly can't just ignore it.
Uh...
Boy.
I think we've lost our chance.
Uh...
What was my chance?
Was it with the rock?
Or...
Um...
Maybe when I launch this up, it's...
I attach myself to the rock?
Or...
I guess we'll just see what happens.
It's gonna launch!
There's no use.
There's nothing we can do from here.
Meow.
Trick time.
Oh.
There goes the missile.
Now there's really nothing we can do.
If only our missile was here right now.
And Becky tried to take it head on for us.
Yeah, I bet he would.
Looks like we better rethink this whole thing.
Okay, from the fate change.
There goes missile but not the dog.
So I think I have to attach myself to...
The rock.
Right?
When it gets...
Hold on.
Oh, I can't see.
Okay.
I wanted to see if I could...
Grab the rock!
Eat it up!
Okay.
Now.
Uh...
I wonder...
Open!
I wonder if I'm timing this correct...
Correctly.
I don't think I did.
Okay.
One more.
Uh...
You can wait in the light.
Oh, that's right.
You guys are so smart.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait!
No!
Oh, gosh.
I missed...
My chance!
Nice!
Never mind.
I didn't miss my chance.
Wait.
If I'm here...
Oh, I'm in the capsule.
Okay.
Alright.
Poof!
That was so close.
Clutch, man.
Clutch.
From the capsule?
What can I do?
Hmm...
You caught the after image?
I'm just that good.
Do something!
Is it the lever?
Perhaps it is.
Lower the lever.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I'm inside.
Wait.
That's not letting me do anything else.
There's no time!
It's gonna launch!
We can still find a way to stop it.
How?
Even if the torpedo does launch, we just have to stop it from detonating, right?
There's still something we can do.
Okay.
I hope!
Why was the I hope at the end the strongest part of that sentence?
Here it goes!
Oh my god, it literally turns around.
Why is there a mouse in here?
Why is there a mouse in the torpedo?
How did you get in here?
I came along for the ride without giving it too much thought.
Well, was this really the best move?
I think so.
We just have to keep it from going off, right?
Okay, mouse.
I'm sure this poor little rat will thank us too.
Sorry, I kept saying mouse.
You're a rat!
How in the world did it get in there?
Okay.
This game hates rats.
This game is... Oh!
I think these outside parts are supposed to be weights of some sort.
Spinning black things, right?
Apparently their spinning helps the torpedo maintain its balance.
They must be pretty heavy.
I wonder if we can use these weights to our advantage somehow.
Stop!
Operate.
Okay.
Let's examine the detonator.
This is probably the detonator.
Don't press it!
The torpedo will explode!
Uh-oh.
Better be careful.
But you know, there should be a safety device around here somewhere.
Safety device, huh?
That sounds promising.
We have to put the safety on before this thing blows up.
Wait, what's the dialogue here?
Press it!
Do you know how a torpedo works?
No, I can't say I do.
Wow, detectives sure know a lot.
I saw it explained once in a book.
On impact, the fuse in the...
Okay, someone tell me if this is accurate.
I'm so curious.
On impact, the fuse in the tip is depressed.
Uh-huh.
That, in turn, sets off the detonator.
Woah!
The detonator, huh?
That must be the red button.
Kinda not a...
Wait, so there's like a tiny little red button inside a torpedo?
Oh...
That sounds so silly, though.
There is?
For real?
Probably won't be a button.
Hahaha.
IRL torpedoes have rats in them, too.
Wow!
More of like an igniter.
Okay, that makes more sense.
So how do we stop it?
It didn't explain anything about that in the book.
Wow, detectives sure know a lot.
Or not.
Okay, uh...
Let's operate the joint.
Oh!
Oh my...
This looks like...
Just a thing.
If we clamp down...
Clamp this thing on the fuse, it should keep it from moving.
So what does that mean exactly?
It means we might be able to stop the torpedo from exploding with this.
I have to admit, I don't understand all the details.
But I do want to give it a try.
Before we can do that...
Looks like we have to get...
Something out of the way first, huh?
Um, little rat...
Little rat... Okay.
I think if we stop it in a certain way, it will fling the rat.
He'll be like...
Either like...
Woo!
Or he'll be like...
You know?
Let's try stopping this one.
Oh god!
Maybe I was wrong.
Uh...
What?
How do I get you out of here?
Stop!
Nope!
When I stop one...
Wait.
Huh?
When I stop one, the other one starts.
Oh!
Wait a second.
Oh, I had to time it.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Wait.
We've dumped the little creature off.
Okay.
Those weights were heavy enough to turn the whole torpedo over.
Nice!
I...
I knew that was gonna happen.
Now for that safety device.
Right!
Oh my god.
Operate!
There, we clamped the safety device on.
I totally knew that was gonna happen.
That should keep this torpedo from exploding.
But there's just one problem.
Problem?
What's that?
The torpedo is still going to impact.
We can't do anything about that.
Uh oh.
Oh!
As expected of a genius, Minto.
Thank you.
Oh, but it didn't...
The explosion didn't happen so all the stuff didn't come...
It didn't, like, come toppling down the ceiling and stuff.
It looks like the torpedo still hit the sub.
Oh, I got it.
But it looks like the submarine is still...
Okay!
This changes everybody's fate, including the little rat.
Cecil, we did it!
Fate averted.
What's the matter?
You still look unhappy.
Crash is better than an explosion.
Exactly.
We stopped the torpedo from blowing up.
But we still opened up a gaping hole in the submarine.
You're right.
I guess...
I guess that's just what missiles do.
They're unstoppable!
Am I hearing things?
Anyway.
I guess we better get back to the present as quickly as we can.
Right.
I'm worried about Camilla.
I think our best boy is talking.
I think our best boy is hanging about.
We managed to stop death for now.
But it hasn't disappeared altogether.
It's now slowly...
but surely...
filling the room.
Ooh!
Titanic!
Scary!
Uh-oh.
Water is seeping in through the hole where the torpedo hit.
I have to step out.
Here's an early congrats on reaching the end, Mint.
It was so fun to watch.
Poopy!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
We've got to get them out of here.
I'd better go meet up with Lynn.
Trick time.
I like this soundtrack too.
It's so cool.
Uh...
Wheel.
Oh.
What's this one do?
Wheel.
Starter.
Transformer.
Medium fan.
Let's, I guess, start whatever we're starting.
Oh!
The lights went out but this machine apparently still works.
The ride only gets crazier from here?
Oh!
Unfortunately, I guess it won't run for very long.
How much crazier can it get?
Maybe I can use its movements to help me create a path.
I'd better hurry over to Lynn.
It's not safe to stay here.
I just don't have the power to stop that water from coming in.
Wait.
What did I change?
I didn't really change anything.
I don't think at least.
Oh!
That thing right there.
Let's.
Oh!
Uh.
Okay.
Can't do anything with the fans.
But I can.
Do this.
Oh.
A little bit.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Wait.
What can I do with this piston?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
It lifted up.
Oh, phew.
I thought I was trapped for a second.
For real.
Oh my gosh.
She cooking.
Camilla.
Lynn!
Camilla, you're awake.
How do you feel?
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry I pointed that gun at you.
Wait.
So she remembers it.
Camilla's been the manipulator this whole time.
Hmm?
I'm sorry.
Well, how do you remember that, huh, Camilla?
Hmm?
Don't worry about that.
That wasn't you.
Miss Camilla!
Oh, Missle, you're here.
Oh, poor Miss Camilla.
Miss Lynn, what should we do?
We have to get out of here before any more water comes in.
Cecil should be along any second.
I knew Cici would come.
And Missy is here too.
I'm sorry.
I'm so happy everybody's going to be with me now.
Oh, dies.
Uh-oh.
God, I love that dog.
Me too.
I'll get you out of here.
If it's the last thing I do...
Don't say that, Lynn, because it might very well be...
I think I'm going to cry.
Or whimper, as the case may be.
I better send a signal to Lynn that I'm here before it's too late.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's me.
Look at that flashlight.
It's Cecil.
He's here.
That was a quick death flag.
Yeah, it was.
What if there's like a...
Can you imagine?
What if there's like a thing?
A puzzle that we can't solve at some point?
That scares me.
What if, like, Lynn dies and we try to solve the puzzle and she's like, there's no helping it.
It just has to be this way.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
No, I don't want that to happen.
I'm glad you're here, Cecil.
Sorry for the wait.
It looks like this room is going to fill up with water fast.
We'd better get out that door as quick as we can.
We won't be getting out that door, I'm afraid.
The water pressure is too great already.
I can't open it.
What?
What does water pressure mean?
Think of it as the force of the water holding you back.
Cecil is so dumb.
I love this guy.
The water level keeps getting higher and higher in here.
So the only way out of here is up, huh?
Exactly.
Okay.
Got it.
Let's look for a path that goes up.
Which I see one already.
Right there.
Oh, you missed it.
Oh, right there.
Look at that ladder.
I wonder if we can get it down somehow.
Good idea.
Let's try it.
What is water?
Oh, and by the way...
I can't swim!
Neither can Camilla?
Oh my god.
Don't you have any good news for me?
Let me think about it.
In the meantime, could you hurry, please?
Okay.
I'm assuming...
I'm assuming this is time then.
Oh.
What does this do?
Uh...
Handle...
Turn the handle!
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Let's see.
Switch lower.
Nice!
You did it, Sissel!
Thanks!
Big Talabar!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Where is Raiden when you need him?
I know, right?
Listen to the sound of my heartbeat.
Or lack thereof.
Okay.
We're here.
Nice.
What was that?
It looks like water seeping in isn't the only thing we have to worry about.
And I hope you can manage to avoid drowning for two cute girls.
Leave it to me!
Uh-oh.
No!
Our flashlight!
The flashlight doesn't work anymore!
Hey, don't get mad at me.
Maybe the contacts are bad or something.
Hey, I know.
You can fix it with your powers.
I...
Now that's just taking things too far.
Okay.
Uh...
Wait, can I actually turn it on?
Yeah.
You can.
Oh!
It actually worked!
Did you use...
Did you used to be an electrician in your past life or something?
That's a cruel question, considering the circumstances.
Now all we have to do is...
Get to that door and we're safe.
Oh!
Oh my God!
It's actually the Titanic!
Uh...
Listen to the sound of the...
Of the no posters on my wall.
What does that mean?
What happened now?
Looks like the submarine decided to rear up on its hind legs!
I can't believe we're still okay after that fall.
Oh, I mean...
Speak for yourself, but come on.
I mean, there's Camilla right there.
She looks like...
She doesn't look like she's doing so well.
Either we're really lucky or we're dead and we just haven't realized it yet.
Come on now, as if the latter could be true.
Uh...
Camilla!
Oh no way.
What now?
The water sure is rising fast.
Something's rising and it isn't the shield hero.
Come on!
Okay.
Oh my god.
You'll just have to go up!
Up to the top!
Let's see how I can help with my ghost tricks.
What are we gonna do with her?
I think I see a familiar flame over there.
Misa!
Cecil, there you are!
How's it going?
I'd say it was going pretty badly.
Someday it'll be the shield hero.
You guys, what's rising is the water!
It's the water that's rising!
What else would I mean?
It's the water!
You do understand how dangerous the situation is, don't you?
Oh, the water!
Of course!
After all, just ask anybody who knows me about how much I hate taking a bath.
Usually dogs like baths, though.
Have you guys ever...
Have you guys ever met a dog that doesn't like a bath?
Maybe he's been in danger of drowning before himself.
Okay.
Ready to create a path for these ladies?
Of course!
Alright.
Trick time.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Uh...
No, uh, I guess swap, sure.
Oh wait.
Uh...
Let's see.
Where can we... where can we go to?
What can we... oh my goodness.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's so much stuff here!
Oh, I'm feeling a little overwhelmed with this one.
Oh my god.
And we have to get all the way to the top, right?
Here!
Okay.
Uh...
Remember that the water is rising.
Yes, yes.
But they can't swim.
Okay.
And what can we do?
Nothing.
Maybe we have to switch it with a bigger wheel.
Actually, I don't... I don't think... I don't think that's possible.
Why don't we switch first?
My brain is already hurting.
These are the same shape!
What do you mean they can't?
What if I swap these?
Does it do anything?
I don't think so.
I'm just... I'm just switching things to switch them.
I can't believe it's been almost two months since your return.
My brain rotting mind imagined you coming out of a foggy haunted forest.
Stanced up like Heihachi when he came out of the red smoke in Tekken 7.
That's a pretty epic entrance, I'd say.
Thank you.
I need to let time move to see some changes?
Okay.
The water is rising.
Oh my god, that's...
I have to find a way for Lin to get up to the top.
A woman who can't swim and an ambitious woman.
They both head for the top.
I hate their job.
Thanks for joining membership.
To do that, I need to create some kind of foothold for her.
A woman who can't swim and a sensible woman.
They both keep their feet on the ground.
Okay.
Well, so much for waiting for...
So much for waiting.
Okay.
I'm going ghost.
What?
I don't even know what to switch at all.
Don't forget Cecil.
Yeah, but he can't go anywhere right now.
Oh wait, yes again!
What the hell?
Am I stupid?
Am I dumb?
Don't answer that.
So, she was looking at the wheel with the flashlight, wasn't she?
I feel like I need to put like...
Let me talk for hints.
Go up is easier said than done when I'm holding Camila.
I know.
We're going to try to create a path for you somehow.
The water just keeps on rising.
Please hurry.
Oh, and, by the way, did I ever tell you...
You can't swim.
Neither can Camila.
Oops.
I already said that, didn't I?
Okay.
Well, I made up my mind.
Good luck!
Okay...
Oh, my brain...
Wait, operate!
Okay...
Oh!
These pistons sticking out right in front of me!
It's almost like they're taunting me!
Maybe it's a challenge!
It might be just that.
Think you can climb them?
Hmm...
If I wasn't holding Camilla, I could probably do it easily.
Sizzle!
You're not telling Ms. Lin to leave poor Ms. Camilla behind, are you?
Could you be quiet for a minute?
Sizzle, shut the hell up.
These pistons sure do look like they could be used to our advantage.
These pistons...
They're silently pressuring me to climb them.
I doubt they're doing that, Ms. Lin.
It looks like...
It looks like how much the pistons thrust out...
is related to how large the fan...
My arms are full, but my legs are free!
If you could just move these pistons...
so they're a little easier to climb...
I think I could do it.
We need the three different sizes of fans.
Okay.
We had the small one here.
Oops.
I think the small one needs to go...
here.
But we need the large fan.
Wait, okay.
Let's switch the large fan first.
Down here.
No, no, no.
Switch.
Okay.
Okay, medium fan.
Medium fan.
Fine.
Okay.
And then here.
And small fan.
There we go.
Okay.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
ZR, ZR, ZR.
Operate.
There we go.
How about that?
Wow, this is great.
You made a staircase for me.
You better hurry.
I don't think the water is going to wait for you.
Okay.
Yep.
Let's go.
Let's climb.
Thank you.
I think I was trying to see everything all at once.
But now that I'm seeing that it's done in part, it's not so bad, you know?
Okay.
Here she has to avoid the steam.
Yeah, I knew that was going to hurt her.
Now this steam is getting out.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think for this one, we have to see, we have to switch the ones that are pointed down and the ones that are pointed up, you know?
I don't know.
It's too hot to get through.
And there's no way to get around either.
Think you can do something?
Of course we can!
We have to.
Trick time.
Let's get you up there.
Like for example, these two can switch.
Now if they switch... see?
Oh, but that one's pointed...
Ah, that one is flowing both ways.
If I swap the pipes, it changes how the steam comes out.
Because the cracks in each pipe are different!
Yes.
So each pipe sprays out the steam in a different way.
I bet that will come in handy.
But...
Two of them...
Wait, are there any other ones?
That they can swap with?
Doesn't seem like it.
Wait, down...
No, that's the balancer.
Okay, so they have different degrees too.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on!
I have to see!
Oh my gosh...
Here comes the water!
I wish I could drink it up for you.
No, Missile, it's too salty!
I think the more relevant point is that he's dead, so we can't drink it.
Just do something about the steam.
Leave it to me!
Oh, let's try getting Cecil to...
Maybe the... maybe the... what's it called?
Oh no, wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm stuck!
If I operate this...
Can I get back up there?
Oh my god.
I'm stuck!
Oh, there we go.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm still stuck.
There we go.
Okay.
I think we can turn this wheel.
And that will adjust how some of the steam works.
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
But we need...
Okay.
We need this one to switch with this one.
Because this one has the most heavy amount of...
Oh, wait, they both have a heavy amount of...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
I did it!
How does that look?
It looks great!
All that horrible steam is cleared out of the way!
It's not that... it's not far now.
Let's try and move forward.
Ouch!
You swapped perfectly.
First try.
Yeah!
I thought I might have to swap one other one, but...
Nice!
Cool!
Look up there!
If I can just make it to that door!
We can escape!
Now, how in the world am I going to get up there?
Don't yell at me!
If you want to yell, you can yell at me!
Oh my god, no, nobody should yell at you, missile!
You should play the lottery mint?
With my luck?
No way...
Missile, how can I yell at you when you're so sweet about it?
Oh, I think you just did.
Let's look for something to pull Miss Lin up with.
Something to whisk Miss Lin up and glide her ever so gently to the top with.
Hey, are you being sarcastic?
Alright.
No, no.
Let's see what we got here.
A distributing panel.
A switch, a fuse box.
A wheel.
The wheel...
works for...
Wait.
The switch works for this...
for this ladder.
So, what does this...
wheel do?
Hm...
Uh...
Oh!
I'm going ghost!
Okay, let's see...
This switch...
Um...
How can I get over there?
Hm...
Because I think the wheel is what does it.
How can I get over there?
Hm...
Mwa-mwa-mwa-mwa...
Mwa-mwa-mwa-mwa-mwa...
Um... emergency light... pipe...
Oh wait, actually, let's get you out of there.
Let's get to the fuse box and see if there's something we can do here.
Oh!
Open.
Open, sesame!
Okay, ghost.
Now we can open the door.
If I can get this door open, Lin can escape!
I can't budge it.
I must be stuck or something.
I guess we'll have to wait for Lin to use her miraculous power.
Of course we have to get up there.
Oh, we can move the hook!
Easy.
Never mind, I was overthinking.
Now this is what I'm talking about.
Okay, nice.
Okay, raise away!
Alrighty.
Okay, come on, Lin.
Use your super strength.
Girl boss your way through the door.
Sorry, I can't do it.
Open it, hurry!
Is that any way to ask for something?
Oh, am I lagging?
Am I okay?
Oh, I'm lagging a little bit.
Sorry.
Oh!
What am I doing?
Opening?
Together!
It's no use.
I can't budge it.
It must be stuck.
Oh no!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
No!
I got so far, please!
Wait, what just happened?
What the?
The Kraken?
Why am I lagging?
Who?
The doctor?
What just happened?
I can't believe my eyes.
Lin and the little lady suddenly vanished.
Leaving only darkness and sea water.
The submarine continues to sink down.
Down into the deep, deep sea.
But I still want to try and make my way up.
As far as possible.
What just happened?
The Klaaaad.
Still want to head up to find a single ray of light.
Light to illuminate the truth at the bottom of this deep, deep darkness.
Thanks, Cecil.
So poetic.
What just?
Who?
Huh?
The final struggle.
Okay.
What chapter are we on now?
Seventeen?
Seventeen!
Two more chapters!
Oh my gosh.
Strappin'!
Okay.
The upended submarine continues to sink, slowly but surely.
A long, long journey to the bottom of the sea.
Lin and the little lady found the darkness and the salt water closing in on them.
But at the very last second, something saved them.
Now it looks down at them, quietly.
Is it... Ray?
The Klaaaad.
Oh my god, it looks like it has big ol' googly eyes.
My head is filled with one giant question.
What in the world is this thing?
Um...
What?
Eee!
Oh.
That only had enough... What the...
What?
Oh my god, it's...
It's Dark Magician...
Wait, it's Cecil?
I see you managed to survive, detective.
Hey, you're...
Excuse my appearance.
I seem to have lost my body.
He looks so awesome.
Oh no.
I'm into robots.
Oh, and you...
Me?
Minto?
You're the ghost who's been saving Lin all evening, aren't you?
I mean...
I mean, yeah...
I guess you might say that I am the ghost that's been doing all the work, huh?
Yeah...
You knew about me all along?
Of course.
What else would explain all those unnatural things happening?
If you knew, how come you didn't do anything about it all this time?
And how come you decided to save us all of a sudden?
I thought you wanted to get revenge on us.
Fourth wall break real.
I don't really know.
Please, you gotta tell me.
I need to know.
Oh!
I'm back into a wisp.
Who in the world are you?
Cecil, look at you!
What happened?
I can't hold on to that image of myself any longer.
You can't remember who you are?
That's right.
I'm a cool wisp.
It's you guys.
I came all this way tonight trying to chase down my lost memory.
For quite a bit of tonight, I thought I was you, Cecil.
Cecil?
My name isn't Cecil.
Wait, but we knew that.
I bet you'll remember really soon.
Who you are.
And who I am, too.
What?
The man in front of me is not me.
I'm even further away from the truth.
Or maybe not.
Something is stirring in my mind.
A memory about to emerge.
Do I know this man?
Now that I've shed my image of myself, I feel like I'm one step closer to the truth.
Info dump incoming.
Let's go.
But the water...
They got us good.
It's all over for this submarine.
Its engine room is destroyed.
There's a hole in the hole.
Wait, there's a hole in the hole.
In the hu-hull.
And it's sinking as we speak.
What are you doing here?
I thought you had a deal with those people.
They betrayed me.
I was a fool to trust them.
They already have what they wanted now.
But how do they still have the powers?
The Temsik Fragment.
I didn't know they had it all figured out.
You mean they figured out the source of your powers?
A hole in the hull.
Hull.
A hole.
Hole.
In the...
Yeah, that meteorite's radiation has two effects on living creatures.
It gives power and time.
If you don't mind, we'd like to hear more.
Oh, the radiation's power effect.
These ten years.
I've been watching that junkyard superintendent do his research.
You old meme.
Yo Mint, I heard you like drowning so I put a hole in the hole so you can sink while you sink.
And I think I've kind of got some of it figured out.
The meteorite's radiation gives spirits special powers.
Like possessing and manipulating objects.
And in my case, swapping objects.
Exactly.
Apparently there are individual differences in the powers we get.
And it seems these powers change as time goes by.
They do?
Yeah.
My powers have changed over these past ten years.
At first I could only manipulate small living creatures.
Now then.
How do you suppose we got these powers?
It's simple.
It is?
How then?
In a nutshell.
We died while exposed to the energy emitted by the meteorite.
It's radiation.
That's... what does it?
Dying while being exposed to the radiation?
On that day ten years ago.
Oh my gosh.
We actually see his outline.
His silhouette.
Woah!
Oh my god.
Butt up in the air!
Just like how he died again!
A fragment of that meteorite pierced my heart and I died.
So of course I received special powers.
It's a canon event.
Hey, wait a minute!
Is that how I got my powers too?
You know that might be right.
No, I don't want to see it!
No!
Aren't the Temsik remnants still right there in that park at the bottom of the crater?
You're right.
So that must mean...
I must have died in the presence of the meteorite's radiation too.
The radiation's time effect.
Another effect the meteorite's radiation has on us is that it gives us time.
Again, I think this time effect is centered around the theme of death.
But it's not all that clear.
So the fact that I can return to four minutes before a person's death is another effect of that meteorite.
One of the characteristics of that meteorite is its ability to replay the moment of death.
Replay the moment of death?
This is all so strange and confusing!
I can't take it all in!
It makes about as much sense to me as anything else!
Yeah, strange and confusing.
That just about sums up the object that pierced my body that day.
Four minutes death hype.
Thanks to that meteorite fragment, my very existence is a contradiction.
What do you mean?
Contradictory existence?
That day, when the fragment pierced my heart, I lost my life.
However, because it remained inside me, that fragment continued to constantly regenerate my body.
In other words, my body was continuously cycling between the moments that separated my life and death.
My body's vital function stopped ten years ago.
But my body's time is perpetually stopped at the moment just before death.
So that's why he doesn't...
That's why he hasn't...
What's the word?
Oh my god.
Dissolved.
That's why he hasn't dissolved.
His body.
Decomposed.
Yeah, yeah.
I've been trying to think of decompose... that word all night.
And every time I just keep thinking of dissolved.
Time just stopped, huh?
So I just simply existed.
Not really alive.
Not really dead.
That pretty much sums up these last ten years for me.
Ever since that incident in the park.
My body hasn't aged a day.
My hair hasn't grown an inch.
Come to think of it, that old pigeon guy mentioned something.
He said he couldn't cut his... this guy's body with the scalpel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Neither truly alive.
Nor truly dead.
This game is becoming more and more like Metal Gear.
I love your stream.
You are cool.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
So I guess as soon as an incision was made, his body would be regenerated.
Wow.
This guy is just Gray Fox.
Wanting to get revenge.
And also... not being able to be alive or dead.
After Temsik.
Revenge.
Before I left this country, I wanted to do one thing.
I wanted to get revenge on the people who stole our lives.
Our lives?
As part of the deal, I made those guys promise to cooperate.
Cooperate?
You mean the kidnapping?
It all went fine.
I manipulated the justice minister and made him issue the execution order.
But I thought he might call off the execution at the last second.
So that's why you wanted his daughter kidnapped.
But they kidnapped the wrong girl.
Who was our, yeah.
Unless...
Unless also the wife?
No.
Hmm.
Little did I know, they had their own reasons for cooperating with me.
I mean, yeah.
What would they get out of it?
If not, they wouldn't be able to do anything.
They're having their own reasons.
Their objective was to wipe out everybody who had to do with Temsik.
Detective Jowd was one such person.
So they were happy to cooperate.
The professor and Detective Cabanela.
Inspector Cabanela and that junkyard super.
They were slated to be wiped out too.
And as it turns out...
I was one of their targets as well.
So they stole my Temsik fragment.
And here I am.
So cool.
I know, right?
But they had one more final target.
Lin?
You, detective.
Me?
I'm wipeout.
You.
One final target.
Yeah because you were there.
If you weren't there in the park that day ten years ago.
I never would have thought of doing something as stupid as taking a hostage.
Oh, okay...
Totally her fault.
Yep.
With her golden plunger.
Whatever the hell she's holding.
But I was just a little kid playing in the park.
Yeah, I know.
It's your fault I took you hostage!
I know, right?
So... I told you who I was.
So that's why then he manipulated her to shoot him.
And then... then they were going to assassinate her.
But wait, they didn't mean to.
Huh?
She was going to get taken to jail anyway.
You never saw my face that day ten years ago.
So of course you didn't recognize me.
Wait...
Me?
No, no!
He's like, yep.
What can I say?
He's so cool.
Yeah, see then.
I took possession of you to make you shoot me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get the gun.
He's so cool.
Your subconscious resisted me.
Such incredible power.
It was the first time I wasn't able to control somebody completely.
The aim was off and the first shot missed the mark.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
The junkyard was equipped with security cameras.
Wait a second.
The first shot that missed.
That's what killed me.
That's what killed original Cecil.
Wait, but... where?
Where?
Where did it hit?
But it was down!
The junkyard was equipped with security cameras.
I knew you'd be wanted for murder.
That was my plan anyway.
Uh oh.
What if you're a Raccoon?
And then it's, um... Tango!
But they had other ideas.
They simply wanted you wiped out.
Ah, okay, okay.
But then, something threw a big monkey wrench into their scheme.
Because if we're close to the body, if we died close to the body...
Then, of course, we would get the powers.
Are we a rat?!
Oh my gosh, are we a rat?!
We've been a rat this whole time?!
Are we a rat?!
No way...
That's why we've been following the rats!
Oh my gosh, we're a rat!
Remember how I said it's like we're not human?!
Oh my gosh, we're a rat.
I showed up.
You shot a rat!
I was supposed to meet up with them after that.
But then something went wrong.
What happened?
My body disappeared.
Aha, the inspector in white was responsible for that one.
Stop reading chat.
I'm not!
I'm not.
When I'm cooking, I'm really just thinking.
But also, don't spoil stuff.
Do not re-chat?
Okay, I won't re-chat.
Let's stop reading chat.
If you guys are posting spoilers, stop it.
My precious bargaining chip was in that body.
I had to get it back no matter what.
That inspector caused me no end of trouble.
But why were those people targeting me?
I never even heard of the Temsik meteorite.
Because you were looking into the Jout case.
I thought you would find out about Temsik sooner or later.
Okay...
I guess that's... true.
Uh-oh.
How do we get out of here?
This is so titanic, it's scary.
That's pretty much the whole story.
The only thing left to do now is wait for water pressure to crush the submarine.
Oh no!
There's no cores that link from here to the water's surface.
Welcome back after midnight.
Thank you.
I have an idea.
We hook up the phone line and...
There are no communication cables down this deep.
They meant for this submarine to be my coffin.
A coffin for the dead.
There's no escape.
I think I kind of understand now.
What you've been feeling these ten years.
You what?
This feeling.
Cut off from the world all alone in a submarine.
Sinking slowly towards the bottom of an endless sea.
This must be how you felt all along.
Oh!
Camilla's awake!
Lin?
Is it true?
We're stuck here?
What?
At least she's comfy, right?
If my dad...
If my dad was here, I bet he'd save us.
What?
No!
This can't be the end.
Oh, Camilla, I'm so sorry!
That's funny.
What is it, Cecil?
There's something I don't understand.
Why would they go to all the trouble of detaching the control room?
What?
Why didn't they just steal the Temsik fragment and escape if that's what they wanted?
Why did they have to...
jettison your body off into the sea?
Hmm, that's a good question.
Well, because he could still get around, right?
He could still...
But I guess it doesn't matter why now.
We'll never find it again.
We have no idea where it was launched to.
Wait a minute.
Yes, we do?
Oh my gosh, he has the pocket watch!
This will tell us where Detective Jout is.
That present from the inspector in white.
That's right.
Detective Jout told me to hold on to it for him.
And the bullet is still in this person's body in the command room, right?
Oh, nice!
Then we should be able to tell exactly where it is with this.
But even if we find out where it is, how do we get there?
We should be able to figure out something between the three of us.
With our powers.
Right, Ms. Lin?
Right.
Wait.
Are we going to get the manipulating powers?
Wait a minute.
What about a torpedo?
A torpedo?
In any case, it's way too early to give up.
Looks like Detective Jout is our last hope.
Let's get started.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Let's...
We got the bottle.
We got...
The control panel.
Let's operate this.
Beep boop bop beep.
Some grapes.
Nice.
We won't starve.
Okay.
Telephone dial.
Torpedo room.
The torpedo room, huh?
There might be another torpedo left there.
I'll go check it out.
Yeah.
There was one.
You're going to use a missile to ram the control room.
Well, I don't know about ram.
We don't want to blow Detective Jout up, but something like that.
We'll climb up to the torpedo room too.
Up is definitely safer.
I'll see you there then.
Nice.
I like how we still have the glasses on.
Looks like the torpedoes can be launched manually with these switches.
There are two tubes, so there should be one left.
I guess the first thing we have to do is load it into the tube.
When it comes to missiles, you can count on me.
Okay.
I'll enter the coordinates of the command room into the torpedo.
And I just turned on the backup power.
We ought to be able to use the switches now.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Good luck.
So what do I do?
Lower the switch?
Or...
Yeah, lower?
The switch won't budge.
Maybe it's broken?
I don't think the entire device is broken.
It would probably work fine if we could move this switch.
We'll just have to find a way to move it somehow.
I can't do it with my powers alone.
Do you like my sunglasses?
Thanks for the super chat.
It's because he's not a ghost.
He's a shade.
So true.
What kind of ghost do you think I am?
Let's turn this valve.
Let's see what this does.
Nothing.
Do I go to the engine room?
A phantom?
Good guess.
Hmm.
The phone line to the engine room isn't working right now.
Well, that water probably did.
I guess we don't need to go back there anyway.
Okay.
Wait.
Can I get you to move there, missile?
What will happen to these two ladies?
I think that's up to us and our powers.
What?
This is no time to be standing around unsure of ourselves.
Will you lend me your strength, missile?
Me?
Of course I will.
Count on it.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm not quite sure what I...
Oh.
Whoa.
Waste basket.
Basketball.
There's still stuff here.
Telephone.
Emergency light.
Can't reach over there.
Maybe if we go here?
Here?
Still no, but let's try lowering anyway.
Okay.
Didn't do anything.
Where is the torpedo that we're supposed to be... that we're supposed to be putting in there, right?
Or something?
Cleared the same same challenge.
I unlocked the song same same.
Wow.
I had no idea.
Okay.
Here we go.
Your death is a silky ghost made of a house.
Was I made of a house though?
I wonder.
It allows me to go down here, but I'm not quite sure what I'm supposed to be doing here.
Telephone.
Oh, wait a second.
I'm silly.
I'm so silly.
Okay.
Okay, I get what I'm supposed to be doing here now.
Okay, we gotta...
Oh, we're switching the handles!
I get it, I get it now.
I'm silly.
Oh wait, how do I get over into the handle though?
There we go.
Switch!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
And then...
Go back down.
And then we can swap... lower.
Oh wait, I mean, sorry.
The other one, the other one.
Whoopsie.
This one.
Lower!
Okay.
There we go.
The torpedo looks serviceable.
Switching the switches.
I'll set on this end too.
Something's odd.
What is?
The command room.
It looks like it's slowly sinking.
Sinking?
Yeah, like it's completely run out of power.
I wonder what happened.
Uh oh.
I don't know, but I guess I'll find out.
Okay, hop into the missile.
I'll launch it for you.
Thanks.
Here we go.
I'm scared.
Is Detective Jowd gonna be alive?
I've already set the torpedo's course.
It'll head toward the command room where Detective Jowd is.
12 seconds after launching, it'll pass by the command room for an instant.
That instant will be your window of opportunity to jump over to the command room.
Got it.
And then we'll find a way to come back and save you.
That'll probably be my last task tonight.
Just hold on until we get back.
Where did...
Where is...
Where is Evil Sissel?
He didn't...
He didn't show up?
Okay.
Come on, missile.
Missile, you have to come with us.
Missile?
I...
I'm sorry.
I can't go.
What?
I just can't.
How could I leave?
I can't leave Ms. Lin and Ms. Camilla behind.
I can't do it.
Missile.
I swapped the switches so the missile can be launched.
You'll have to do the rest, Sissel.
I can't do it either.
I can't ask Missile to come with me after that.
I understand exactly how he feels.
Yeah, bring Evil Sissel.
Come with us, Evil Sissel.
Okay.
Oh, I guess we're gonna go.
I want you to go, missile.
What?
But Ms. Lin!
You staying here won't change our fate.
But if you go with Sissel, you might be able to make something happen.
And that's our only hope.
But what if that something doesn't happen?
I'll never be able to see you again.
Never ever again.
Even I can understand that.
I couldn't stand that.
Don't worry, missile.
Miss Camilla.
I just know you and Sissy can make something happen.
I believe in you.
I'll be right here waiting for you.
We'll see each other then.
Don't worry.
Miss Camilla!
Here he goes.
That's a good boy, missile.
Why'd you have to make such a lovable dog?
Are you ready?
Remember, it's 12 seconds after I throw this switch.
We're ready.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I hope.
It's gonna count down for me, right?
Sissel?
Yes?
We never found out who you really were.
But that doesn't matter now.
All I know is I'm truly glad I met you tonight.
Thank you for everything.
And I'm glad I met you, detective.
Well, we're going to see each other again.
Right, Sissy?
Right, missile?
That's right.
We promised, little lady.
Of course we will!
I'll never forget you.
No matter what happens.
This is such a death flag.
Oh, my God.
Here goes then.
Don't promise that you'll never see me again.
Don't promise anything.
Good luck, friend.
These 12 seconds are lasting an eternity.
I strive to think of a way to save Lin and the little lady the whole time.
But how can a ray of light...
A ray?
...of hope reach this far down into the deep sea?
Before I can think of an answer, the 12 seconds are up.
Wow!
Woo!
Uh-oh.
There they go.
Detective Jowd!
I bet that big masked man did this.
I'm going to bite him.
Yeah, you bite him.
You better not.
You might break your teeth.
The command room has lost power and is sinking.
So I wonder what this masked man is going to do.
Just sacrifice himself?
He's going to sacrifice himself!
No!
You won't!
You can't!
Let's talk to Detective Jowd.
Sorry for the wait, Detective Jowd.
Who are you?
Are you Cecil?
Please excuse my appearance.
I can't believe you made it here.
How is Camilla?
And what about Lin?
Well, it's kind of a long story.
Then that's how they explain it really quickly in Animal Crossing talk.
I told Detective Jowd about everything that happened on the submarine Yo Mama.
So the submarine is badly damaged?
Why would he do that to his own submarine?
I wish I knew.
I know the answer to that one.
Whoa!
It's because he's afraid of my powers.
Hey!
Excuse me?
You!
You followed us?
I didn't even notice.
It's been 10 long days.
It's been 10 long years, Detective Jowd.
Are you...
Yo-Me-El?
So you remember me, do you?
How could I possibly forget?
So that's your real name, huh?
Yo-Me-El?
That's interesting.
That's right.
But those people on...
on the Yonoa were calling you Cecil.
That's just an alias I was using for my deal with them.
I didn't see any need to tell them my real name.
Could you do me a favor?
Would you let me ask you some questions?
I've been trying to find out my true identity all night.
Yo-Me-El is named after a fallen angel and Yomi, the Shinto land of the dead.
In Shu Takumi tradition, most character names in the game are puns and references.
In this case, related to death.
Interesting, interesting.
It's Yo-Me-El, so yep, you're reading it right.
Okay, nice.
Thank you!
Sure, go ahead.
I'm sure there's plenty we can still tell you, right, Detective Jowd?
Right.
About Yo-Me-El.
10 years ago...
You were a systems engineer, weren't you?
Systems engineer?
What's that?
By the way, I'm a top Pomeranian, you know?
Yes, you are, missile.
Well, it's kind of hard to explain to a dog, but it's a person who's good at using computers.
I don't mean to brag, but I was one of the best in the industry.
Oh my god, he's a hacker.
That's how I got roped into joining that project.
Project?
What project?
It was a project aimed at reorganizing the nation's top secret information.
The goal was to build a new system using multi-dimensional programming theory.
I was asked to join the project by an agent of the government.
It doesn't sound like something a top Pomeranian would know anything about.
To me, it just sounded like another challenging job.
Hackerman.
However, this project was also the target of a secret plot.
I bet you can imagine the kind of crime the nation's top secrets might attract.
I never thought for the life of me I'd ever have to deal with spies.
It was never made public, but every organization in the country moved on this one.
And then one day, the name of a certain programmer emerged as a suspect.
I was the guy who built the core of the system.
The police arrested you, and then that incident happened.
He escaped from the interrogation room and took little Lin as a hostage.
Hold on one second.
I gotta check something real quick, guys.
Sorry.
Uh...
Okay.
Never mind.
I never got an answer.
Hahahaha.
By the way, Detective Jowd...
When was it that I was proven innocent?
About six months after your death.
I'm so sorry, Yomiel.
He was framed.
Real motive for revenge.
Ten years ago.
My soul was split from my body and I lost everything.
I was sealed in eternal darkness.
Uwaaaah!
Look at he go ...
I existed in this world, no question about that.
But nobody noticed my presence.
Look at him go!
What good were my powers?
they didn't help anybody.
I would even the passage of time, peel my pain.
In fact, it only made worse.
The worst.
Aww...
And so that's why you murdered Alma.
That's right.
I wanted you to know what it was like to lose everything you cared about.
I wanted you to feel the same pain I felt.
What?
But that's not entirely right, right?
It was the twisted wish of a mind poisoned by infinite loneliness.
Yeah.
And then, as I was plotting my revenge, I had an idea.
I came up with a plan to use these powers of mine to make a deal.
The deal.
What's the deal?
What's the deal with Ghost Trick?
There's something I just don't understand about that deal.
I'm sure your powers would be very valuable to them, but what would you get out of the deal?
A new life.
Life?
I asked them for two conditions.
Number one was that they helped me with my revenge plot.
And the second was a rebirth for me.
Rebirth?
A new beginning, eh?
I didn't care if it was a fake life or an artificial life.
I just wanted a physical receptacle for my soul.
A name, an identity, an everyday life.
I wanted to grow old in a society that would accept me.
And finally, I wanted to die surrounded by a loving family.
That's the kind of life I asked them for.
A completely man-made life.
Step one.
Revenge.
Step two, become baby.
That's right.
I knew I couldn't hope for anything more than that.
To make it all come true, I knew it would take a lot of money and a lot of power.
That's why I decided to ask a national government to help me.
And their response in the end... was betrayal.
Betrayal.
They were making their moves much more carefully than I suspected.
They sent spies to this country and researched my powers on their own.
And...
They even figured out what Temsik was all about.
And you had no idea they were doing all this?
None at all.
I was a fool.
So then...
Why did they go to all the trouble of making a deal with you?
Why didn't they just steal a hunk of the Temsik meteorite from the park?
They couldn't.
After the manipulator incidents, research was conducted in this country too.
A report was submitted to the government about the source of the manipulator's power.
Okay...
By Inspector Cabanela and the Old Pigeon Guy, eh?
At first the government didn't believe the report.
But then they decided to put...
Put the park under surveillance just in case.
Wait...
It's not the hippie guy, is it?
Surveillance, huh?
It looks like an ordinary peaceful park.
But there are armed agents there all the time!
Like him!
Don't tell me that odd leaflet guy is one of them.
No, not him.
He's just a plain old odd person.
Okay.
He's just a weirdo.
Just a weirdo, everybody.
Nothing to see here.
That park is like a silent battlefield on an international scale.
So that's why they couldn't steal the Temsik meteorite.
And lately, under the pretense of building a housing site, they've been working on a plan to destroy that park in order to secure the Temsik meteorite.
Oh, so that's it.
So the upshot of your grand deal...
was this, eh?
Yeah.
It's the ending I deserve.
But at least there's one thing you must be happy about.
What's that?
You've managed to seal me away at the bottom of the sea forever.
Well?
Shall we get started?
Started with what?
Bringing Detective Jowd back to life, of course.
What?
What good will that do now?
But we promised!
We promised Ms. Lin and Ms. Camilla we'd save them.
And we can't do that without you, Detective Jowd.
I've been guided by fate to save you.
We'll get tonight to this place.
I won't give up now.
All right, fine.
Let's see where it leads us.
Gosh, there's so much reading, you guys.
I'm getting so tired.
I'm sorry.
Here we go, then.
Back to four minutes before your death.
Trying to get hungry, too.
You're almost at the end.
We have one more chapter after this.
But this shouldn't be so much reading, probably, because we're figuring out the puzzle.
Hang in there!
Thank you!
So, where are we headed?
We are not headed anywhere, Detective.
For the mystery of Cecil's identity, you have been given all the clues needed.
Take a hot minute before diving into the final chapter.
For chat, hush.
No spoilers.
No, it's okay.
I think I will just go into the final chapter.
It's no worries.
I want to see what they...
I think I've cooked enough.
You know?
I think I want to see what the answer is.
What?
There was only enough fuel on board to launch us away, Detective.
We will run out soon and that will be our destination, Detective.
Wait, does this guy actually just sacrifice himself?
What are you talking about?
That would mean that you're trapped here, too.
By the way, I am not human, Detective.
I
am a remote-controlled robot, Detective.
What?
Your country's use of technology is just playing off.
We get that a lot, Detective.
I don't know.
Give me robot girls and I'm in.
Actually.
Why would you go to all this trouble to do this?
It's nothing but a shell there.
It's hardly a threat anymore.
Commander Sith likes to provide against any possibility.
No matter how small, Detective.
Possibility.
Yeah, we got robot girls.
We have blue women.
I think this other country is great.
Hahaha.
Where's my robot girls at?
What are you talking about?
There's no need for you to know, Detective.
Smack.
Oh!
Now it's time to say goodbye, Detective.
Murph, thanks for a month.
Thank you.
In the end, your fate remains the same, it seems, Detective.
Grr.
Camilla, forgive me.
Maybe Shaggy is a robot.
Good.
I can't wait to dismantle that guy.
To teeny tiny pieces.
By every little bit and bot.
It's not over yet.
Not yet, child.
Remember what that big masked man said?
Any possibility, no matter how small.
Possibility.
In other words, there must be a chance here somewhere.
The possibility of turning this situation around.
Do we get other powers?
Do we get the powers of...
Of...
Do we get the powers of manipulation?
Okay, let's see what we got here.
Huh?
What is it, Detective?
Look at Yomiel's shell.
There's no aura emanating from his body.
Of course there isn't.
The Temsik Fragment is gone.
Could this change in his shell give us some kind of lead?
I don't know.
I figured it out.
I know what this possibility, no matter...
That was fast.
This possibility, no matter small...
No matter how small, is that...
Is that they are afraid of.
What?
What is it?
That was so fast.
My time was perpetually stopped thanks to the power of Temsik.
His body cycled between the moments that separated his life and death.
But not anymore.
Wait.
Can we?
The Temsik Fragment has been taken away.
So what does that mean?
No...
I get it.
Your body won't come back to life anymore.
The moment the Temsik Fragment was removed, my shell became a regular corpse!
Huh?
But...
That means we can... we can go back four minutes before your death?
But wait a minute.
Exactly... when is that death?
Ten years ago?
That's simple.
We'll find out...
when we get there!
Let's move!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
How do we stop a whole ass meteor?
I fell back through the cracks of time for what seemed like forever.
And then I saw it.
The final death.
At the end of this long night.
Who exactly am I?
I've already seen all the clues.
All I have to do now is remember.
The final journey to the truth starts now.
Oh!
Okay.
Final chapter, everybody.
Four minutes before death variation.
Oh, cool!
Oh, awesome!
Okay, here we go, everybody.
Last chapter.
Final chapter.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
When was Yomiel's death?
It was ten years ago, when the Temsik meteorite fell.
We traveled back through time, and now we're here at the scene of that death.
The start of it all is about to replay itself.
Oh my gosh.
Here comes the meteor.
Four minutes before death.
Oh wow, what a pretty park!
Oh my gosh, it's so cute!
She's jamming.
It's...
What?
Oh my gosh, she was making...
She was making yakiimo!
She was making sweet potato!
I thought it was a plunger.
Give it up.
Do you really think you can outrun me?
She was cooking.
Let her...
Eek!
Now just calm down and drop that weapon!
Stay back!
Have you come any closer?
Think you can already get who you are?
I have no idea anymore.
I'll shoot her!
Oh, a baby!
Huh?
Oh, a kitten.
Random cat.
You might get hurt.
It's beautiful!
Oh my gosh.
And then, the whole human race was extinct.
Oh, okay.
Is that gonna have to do something with it somehow?
Stellar!
The cat's okay, right?
Are you okay?
Where'd the cat go?
You're all right now.
Are you hurt?
You saved me, mister!
Oh, wait, hold on.
Um...
You saved me, mister!
I was just doing my job.
The gods.
They're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, mister?
Me?
I'm a police detective.
No!
So that's the Temsik video, right guy?
It's beautiful looking at it.
Oh, it's beautiful looking at it from this angle.
It changed all of our fates completely.
We can't stop Temsik from falling from the sky.
But we might be able to protect you from the fragment and save your life.
I'm so glad you played one of my favorite games.
The gameplay and story is 10 out of 10.
I hope you'll play more games like this in the future.
Also, 10 out of 10 voice acting.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
I don't know.
What's the matter, Detective Jao?
To be perfectly honest, I'm scared.
If that meteorite fragment doesn't get him, I'm pretty sure I would have shot him.
We might not be able to change your fate of dying.
I can accept that.
No!
What I did is inexcusable.
No matter how the future might change, that fact will never go away.
It's my fate to die here, then I accept that.
Oh, if my fate is to die here, then I accept that.
This will be our last battle against fate.
Beyond that will be a new future.
Okay, let's get started!
My soul is still here!
I'm so happy!
Okay.
I feel like we're gonna have to probably use Missile's powers to swap something, right?
Alright, let's see what we got here.
We can't... I can't reach.
Missile's just hanging out in the basket.
Got a nozzle.
Maybe we have to shoot the...
Hmm...
Roasted sweet potato!
I want roasted sweet potato so badly right now!
Headphones...
Okay.
We don't have much going on here.
It's ready!
Let's make it!
Oh!
Okay.
Examine the sweet potato.
What in the world is this thing?
It's making me hungry.
Well, well, what can I do?
I did it!
Oh boy.
You even forgot what a sweet potato is?
It's a roasted root vegetable.
That's good!
I love... Oh my gosh.
If you've never had roasted sweet potato, it's one of the best things ever.
So good.
There's nothing like them on a cold...
Like them on a cold winter's day.
They're sweet and they smell delicious!
These guys sure are making me want to try one.
Okay...
Still can't reach.
Hmm...
I have to switch this and this.
I have to switch this and this, I think.
Right?
The god rock.
Yeah.
Can I go grab some food real quick?
Sorry.
It's already done.
So I'm just gonna grab it.
I'll be...
Two seconds to grab it.
Okay.
Sorry, I started to get shaky all of a sudden.
Oh, I'm a hungry ghost.
I'm a hungry ghost.
Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry for the break.
So sorry.
I want to continue the story.
I want to see what happens.
But I need brain...
I need fuel for my...
For my mushy brain.
Okay.
Hmm...
Sorry, I won't be able to voice act this part, I think.
We're missing in.
I'm sorry.
If you're so sorry, then put it down.
I mean, I won't be able to voice act this.
Just reads it anyway.
All right.
Now, missile.
I was really out of my head that day.
We can talk about all this later.
The Temsec meteorite is going to fall very soon.
Before that happens, I have to think of a way to do something about that fragment.
And I'll do everything I can to help too.
Okay.
We really don't have very many places we can go.
Let's...
Let's have some more time pass.
Look at the cat.
Time is passing.
Oh, so cute.
Nothing else happens.
It's about time for that meteorite to come down.
Uh-oh.
We have to change the direction.
We have to change the fragment's path somehow.
Looks like both paths and fates can be difficult things to change.
There has to be a way.
If we work together, you and me, I thought we'd be able to do something.
Thought?
That's funny.
I wonder why he's using past tense.
So cute.
Kind of reminds me...
It reminds me of Paz.
My
turn.
Okay.
Let's redo it.
So this is the start of it all, huh?
If we can change Rukyomiya's fate, what will happen to everything else, I wonder?
It won't do us any good to think about that now.
Right.
We just have to take that first step forward.
Just as we always do.
Rewind!
Oh...
Okay.
I can't reach until he grabs her.
Why can't we switch around?
Is the basket and the...
Are the basket and the sweet potato, when she grabs them, are they the same shape?
Let's see.
Do they count as the same shape?
Hehehe.
This cat just walks up.
So funny.
Oh, no it doesn't.
Oh man, I already missed my opportunity, maybe.
We can examine the sweep...
Oh!
We can turn off the headphones!
Oh, I didn't realize that.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What are you doing?
You're going to hurt poor Miss Lin's ears!
I'm sorry, I wasn't thinking.
You really startled her.
You could have made her drop her sweet potato.
I know...
I know how much this girl loves her food too.
Anyway, at least her fate has been changed, albeit ever so slightly.
Okay, I'm going ghost.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
We're going to have you go all the way...
Not there.
Oh, wait!
We have to go from here to there.
There we go.
Okay.
We can rock the basket.
We can spray the nozzle.
Okay, I was thinking that.
Spray...
Can I switch the nozzles?
Oh, I can't reach.
I was going to say, if I could switch the nozzles, maybe one will be...
He could like spray Cecil, you know?
Alright!
Thank you!
Yuki...
Oh gosh, I didn't see the other name.
I'm so sorry.
YouTube is really stupid right now.
And all raids come in a white text on white background, so I can't read them.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Oh, Yuki and Yuna!
Thank you!
Right now, I'm in the final chapter of this game.
So, kind of major spoilers, but...
You're welcome.
Let's see.
Come here, everything's for the gifted!
Let's rock this I guess.
Let's see what happens here.
Rock the boat.
Oh!
Oh, and we shoot it up!
Um...
Ghost!
Oh!
Oops!
Wait, I pressed the wrong button.
What did I just press?
Oh!
Okay!
That scared me.
Heart on your blade!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Shopkeeper, thank you for the five gifted!
I said thank you guys!
Okay.
Here we go.
And shoot!
Oh.
Uh oh.
Wait, I think I missed my opportunity.
That was kind of disappointing.
Maybe the timing was a little off.
I better try it again.
How do I...
Get it back over here though?
Oh!
I had it!
I didn't have it!
Okay.
Let's just restart.
After the fight change.
Okay.
We have one chance.
Rock the boat.
And then go to here.
And then back.
And then...
Oh my god!
I can't see it!
Okay.
Go, ghost!
No!
Nice!
Oh!
Okay.
Look at that sweet potato!
That big scary sweet...
That big scary sweet potato!
That's not a sweet potato missile.
That's Minto!
You guys, I'm a sweet potato.
I can't believe I'm in the game.
All right.
Of course.
But look at them.
The potato and Minto.
Right now, they both have the same shape.
So you're saying you could swap them, huh?
Good idea, missile.
Here I go.
And I'm gonna need your help.
My help?
Oh, spray higher.
Pew!
Wait a second.
No, no.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's all I can do.
I can't...
Um...
I had it.
What do you mean I had it?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
But why do I...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Can I reach it now?
No.
Can I reach it from here?
Okay.
Good boy.
I need you to move, sisso.
You're in my way.
You're in my way, sisso.
It's right there.
Come on.
Hey, hey, hey.
Don't be mean about it, okay?
Okay, just because I get something not as quickly as you do, doesn't mean you have to be mean about it.
Oh my god.
I need you to raise it again.
Raise the roof!
There we go.
Maybe.
I guess.
That was quite a sight to see.
It looks like this park just got a new feature.
But neither one of them even glanced this way!
I guess that's not surprising, seeing as even a meteorite didn't distract them.
Hey, it was a desperate situation.
Kill or be killed.
And Yeomiel is killed right after this, by the meteorite.
Well, now that the park has a new feature, we can use it to...
To our own advantage in any...
Or can we use it to our own advantage in any way?
Okay.
Cleared the first...
Wait, wait, wait!
What can you do?
Spray any high or...
You're literally stuck.
Okay, Cecil is stuck.
Stuckle.
Yeah, let's try the water.
Just a tiny bit.
There's no use.
I can't get any water to come out.
Well, we can see why not.
Yeah, the overwhelming presence of Minto.
If only we could use it to our advantage somehow.
How can we use it to our...
Um...
Is there anything that I can...
Anything that I can...
What can I do with it?
With it...
Oh, wait!
Post lantern.
Um...
Hmm...
There's one more core...
There is?
Over here?
No.
I don't know.
I'm trying to figure it out.
I'm just going everywhere, I'm just...
Use it to our advantage.
Use it to our advantage that no water is coming out.
I'm only glancing at chat sometimes.
Even if people are giving answers, I'm most likely not seeing it.
You guys can be like, stop back-seating!
But it's okay, I'm not watching.
I'm not looking at it either.
I'm not really seeing anyone telling me what to do either.
Oh, here we go.
I guess we'll just play it out and see what happens.
I doubt we can move those two from that spot.
Which means we have to do something with the Temsik fragment instead.
That should be easy with our pow- What do you mean with the fragment, huh?
I think you're right, Missile.
This is going to be the grand finale.
Do something with the fragment?
Oh my gosh, I forgot it was from all the way back here.
Rock!
Oh my gosh, I can't see it.
Spray!
Yeah, and that's there.
And then, spray higher.
Oh wait.
Can I reach it?
Yeah.
Like that.
And then we go back about here.
Can I go down just a little bit?
Right there?
Oh, so close!
Wait, can I reach it from here?
Okay, just a little bit higher.
Spray?
Spray, please?
Wait, oh wait.
Oh no, no, wait.
I forgot that I need to do it from down here.
Oh my gosh, it's the timing of it.
Maybe here?
Reach?
Way overthinking.
What are you talking about?
Okay, reach.
There we go.
Now I have to do it.
Okay.
Now, now, there we go.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, spray please.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm good.
Swap.
Okay.
This is
what I wanted to do from the beginning.
The lamppost is bending.
But it hasn't broken yet.
It really is a wonder it hasn't snapped.
It just might hold out for a little while longer.
If I recall, the Temsik fragment smashed through the glass lantern on its way down.
Hmm.
But if Mino sits firmly in its way, then fate should...
Oh, goodbye, Lin.
Goodbye, Lin.
Is there anything else I can do here?
I think...
I think this is it.
There, how's that?
Look, the fragment's course.
It changed a little.
Now Yomiel's fate should really change.
Wait a minute.
Take another look at the fragment's trajectory.
Uh-oh.
Now that it's changed, what's in its path?
In its path?
No!
It only
got hit in the leg, though.
The Temsik fragment shot through his leg.
It's okay.
It's only his leg.
What?
But the cruel twist of fate weren't over yet.
Oh, what do you mean by that?
Um...
Come on, put it down.
Huh?
Jao, put the gun down now!
If you don't, you're going to shoot him!
I don't know if it's his detective training or what.
But even though he's shaking from the pain, the gun doesn't waver.
Put the gun down!
No!
Oh my god.
I knew it.
This is my true fate.
In the end, I stole his life away with my own hands.
Or you missed.
Let's go!
I won't let that happen!
Missile!
But the bullet stopped...
It stopped in mid-air!
I'm here inside the bullet!
Now let's swap it with something.
What?
With what?
Detective Jao.
The meteorite fragment is what made you pull the trigger.
We won't let you become a matee...
A meteor?
We won't let you become a...
Mm-hmm.
We have to prove that murder isn't the detective's true fate.
To do that, we have to stop this bullet.
There must be something with the same shape as the bullet around here.
Eat that!
Sorry,
that was really loud.
Oh my god!
We stopped the bullet.
But we still couldn't save him.
That's not true.
My fate of getting pierced through the back might not have changed.
But I'm still alive.
What?
I'm not dead.
I'm just unconscious.
I mean, for now.
Okay, so your fate of death has changed.
But still...
This fate is just too painful to watch in every sense.
I don't think so.
As long as I'm alive, that's good enough for me.
But we were overlooking one thing.
We were overlooking...
The wheel of fate was still slowly turning.
Wake up!
You gotta get out of there!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Damn it, my leg won't work!
It's all over!
We're out of time!
Miss Lin!
It's not over yet!
But there isn't anything else to swap with!
Why don't we just let it play out and then try to find another way next time?
Even if she dies, all you have to do is possess her corpse.
And then you can redo her last four minutes as many times as it takes!
Wait, that's what I...
No, I won't do that!
Why not?
Sure, the fact of her death would be erased.
But her memory of it would remain like a scar on her psyche.
I won't let that happen.
Not if I can help it.
But what can we do now?
Even if we work together?
I think there might be something that can be done.
What is it?
What can Cecil and I do?
Don't forget, I'm here too.
We finally...
Finally!
Oh wow.
You know, you could have helped out at any point in the past.
With three kinds of powers among us...
Among us?
We ought to be able to fight this battle.
This battle against the fate of death!
Yomiya!
Cecil, your power is manipulating objects.
Use your power to manipulate this!
Huh?
I don't get it.
Just trust me.
Just go!
Alright, I'll try to move there.
Now gather your strength and make it spray...
as if your life depended on it!
I'm dead though.
He's just like me, for real, for real.
In that case...
Make it spray as if your death depended on it!
Give it your all!
And remember...
You only have a split second.
Okay, now do it!
Got it!
Okay...
Oh!
Now it's your turn, Missile!
What?
Me?
But what can I do?
I think you know an answer to that.
Okay, got it!
You can swap them!
That hunk of concrete will go back to its original position!
Wait, but...
It's still going to be flying through the air.
Wait, I don't think you thought this through.
But...
Even if I swap them, it's still going to be right above Miss Lin!
Yeah!
Don't worry.
Okay, I'll do it!
I'll swap them!
Okay...
It's no use!
We can't stop that horrible Mino!
What can we do now?
I don't see how gaining a second or two helped.
Oh, it helped, all right.
Those few seconds were exactly what I wanted.
Last up, it's my turn.
Your turn?
Him.
You know what my power is, right?
That's right.
I can manipulate living creatures.
Wait a minute, you mean...
That's right.
I'm going to save that little girl.
Save her by manipulating my own unconscious body.
Penny redeemed himself.
Oh my god.
You're awake.
Mister, is your knee okay?
Oh, it'll be fine.
It's just a scrape.
I'm lucky it wasn't a fatal hit.
But the main thing is that you're not hurt.
You saved me, Mister.
I was just doing my job.
The gods, they're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, Mister?
I'm a police detective.
Do you think you can save me?
Do you think you could go call the police for me?
I think you could do it quicker than I could.
But...
What's that?
This is a detective's badge.
We give them to children who've been very brave.
A detective's badge?
Aww.
No!
So cute!
Thanks!
You know what to do, little detective.
Are you alive?
Yeah, sadly.
He's still alive!
I thought it was a lollipop, too.
Hang on.
Help is coming.
What made you do such a reckless thing?
To be perfectly honest, I don't really know.
They all don't remember.
We basically went back in time entirely.
When I came to, my body was already moving by itself.
As if... It was as if somebody else was controlling me.
I see.
But you know...
I'm glad it happened.
I found this kitten that was over there.
No, no, no, no.
Come to think of it...
I just saw it a few minutes ago.
It's probably astray.
It's alive, right?
It's kind of limp.
Is it okay?
I don't know.
I think it's unconscious.
Okay.
It's unconscious.
It's funny.
It doesn't look like it's injured or anything.
Okay.
Poor little kitty.
How about if I take it to my house and look after it?
Would you like to come home with me, little kitten?
Well, it looks like his fate just changed in a big way.
Whose fate?
That kitten's, of course.
You're a suit.
Why did you have to...
In the middle!
Hey!
Sizzles!
Sizzle?
The name Sizzle echoes in my head.
That's my real name.
So we weren't a rat.
We were a cat!
These long, lonely ten years.
You were my one and only friend.
No, me?
How about it?
Do you remember now?
So cute!
Old friend.
Oh my god, we're awesome!
I think...
I think I finally remember.
Ten years ago, I was a little kitten that wandered into this park.
I was weak and all alone in the world.
Hold it!
God, why am I crying?
Somebody please look at me!
No!
The kitten!
That's why I didn't know anything!
So cute!
Somebody please reach a hand out to me!
No!
Oh, and he can manipulate!
I had just only died at the time.
I had lost everything.
My life, my memory.
My body wouldn't move anymore.
But I still managed to reach out a hand to him.
And the next thing I knew, my soul had transferred to the black kitten.
With no recollection of who I was, I lived as a cat with you for a while.
After a while, the man regained his memory.
And went back to being just a cat.
And then the man got his body back.
Gosh, I wish I were a cat.
I took my body back from the morgue.
There was somebody I just had to go see.
Just one more time.
I took control of my body and hurried to her house.
But I was just a little too late.
His wife!
I had just missed her as she left this world.
She left me a note that said, I'm coming to you, Yomiel.
The man named me Sissel.
It was the name of something important he had lost along with his life.
His fiancée.
He told me about it once.
But I didn't understand what it was.
Those ten years were very happy for me.
But they weren't happy for the man.
There was nothing I could do for him.
For ten years I wandered through the darkness.
With no particular place to go.
As time passed, my powers gradually changed.
At first I could only manipulate small creatures and objects.
But then after a while I could manipulate people.
That's when the darkness inside me deepened and I started to get a little twisted.
I wanted light.
Distorted artificial light.
When I got my revenge on Lin...
I would see that light.
Or at least that's what I tried to believe.
I left my old self buried in that junkyard and walked away.
Wait, did we see this before?
I don't remember.
The black cat.
I was possessing Cissel then.
It wouldn't look very much like a murder if the corpse got up and walked away, after all.
But what was that about?
Yeah, we did wait back, right?
Yes.
So you borrowed the body of your old friend.
Awww
Cissel was in the dark.
What was inside that bag I was carrying tonight?
Why would you bring your cat?
I had no intention of leaving my friend behind in this country when I left.
But then, when I went to possess his body...
I realized something horrible.
What was that?
Is this still there inside the bag?
Oh
man, why do I have to kill the cat?
Not the cat!
The cat!
I wasn't able to control her completely.
No!
The first bullet didn't hit anything.
Or so I thought.
But it did hit something.
It hits it so much!
That's so sad.
That's when I lost my life.
Right there in the presence of Temsik radiation.
And that's when I got my powers of the dead.
My ghost tricks.
I think I understand it now.
Why I was the only one who couldn't get his memory back.
It was because I thought that corpse was me.
Yeah, because he took off with the body!
It was the only corpse I could see at the time after all.
But as it turns out, it wasn't the only dead body.
My true death was hiding just behind that corpse.
Now that I think about it, do you remember what you said?
That you knew all along about me saving Lin tonight?
And if you knew, why didn't you try to stop me?
It's simple.
Because I couldn't, even if I wanted to.
Why not?
Remember the thing about individual differences and the powers we get?
I can control all kinds of things, from the living to the dead.
But even so, there are some things that you can do that I can't.
You mean...
I can't even rewind time, let alone change the fate of a death.
If I could do those things, I would have saved your life.
Not only that, but I never would have just let my fiancé stay dead like that.
But you're here ten years in the past now!
That's thanks to your powers!
I just tagged along with you.
In any case, now the starting point of this entire tragedy has changed dramatically, altering fate.
The fate of your death.
The Kitten Sissel's fate.
And I can just bet you the fate of the woman you love has changed too.
I believe you're right.
So this was the last fate to be averted, eh?
Why do you have to still play the animation?
So, Yomiya...
It looks like your plan for revenge ended in failure.
Yes, and I'm glad too.
I think I kind of understand now.
What you've been feeling these ten years.
Oh yeah...
She understood.
She shed tears for me.
That's when my revenge was over.
She saved me from the darkness.
Well, I guess it's time we got back.
A new ten years later was just born.
What's gonna be different?
Right, we should get back to our new present.
Oh, Miso!
I can't wait to see Ms. Lin and Ms. Camilla again!
So these past ten years will all vanish.
Will they remember?
Well, not completely.
The memories of all of us here will remain.
Wait, what about Camilla and Lin too then?
I love seeing this game.
It's my favorite game after MGS3 or 4.
Including the memory of what I did.
My crime.
That's the way this game of the dead works, eh?
And no matter what the reason.
There's no denying the fact that I took Lin hostage and tried to point a gun at her.
I have no intention of running away from that either.
The most inexcusable crime in my new life.
Congrats on beating the game, man.
Thank you!
Hey, Sissel.
Yes?
When we go back, our fates will no longer be interconnected.
It will be like we never met.
So before that happens, I just wanted to say one thing.
Tonight, I stole away your life with my own hands.
I'm truly sorry.
It's already a thing of the lost past.
Our fates have changed now.
Right, Yomiyo?
Thank you, Sissel.
I'm so very glad I met you.
Me too, Yomiyo.
Sissel, are we ever going to see each other again?
I couldn't stand it if we weren't.
Don't worry, Missel.
I bet we'll see each other again someday.
Ten years from now, our paths are sure to cross.
We'll just have to wait until then.
Sissel, I'll...
I'll never forget you!
I'll never forget you either, valiant little doggie.
Well, it looks like you've come to live with me now.
So let's be getting home, little black cat.
Home, huh?
That sounds good, Detective Jaud.
We all witnessed the birth of a new beginning.
And now, we're each going back to our own new present.
This is all so weird.
We said goodbye to the parts of our stories that would be lost.
Believing that someday our paths would all cross again.
Well, I mean, if you have your memories still, you can just...
You can all just meet up again, right?
Wait!
Hold it!
Before you go back to a new present, I wanted to thank you.
Is this Ray?
Is this the lamp?
Before I cease to exist.
Oh, it's you!
Yes, it is I, Ray, in case you have forgotten again.
Thanks to you, everything has turned out as I had hoped.
I'm really grateful to you, Cecil.
Thank you.
But don't forget, I was only on a journey to find my own lost memory.
Yes, yes, I know that.
I know all about you.
Can I ask you a question, Ray?
I want to know, who exactly are you?
Fair enough.
I will tell you.
Let me tell you about another version of tonight's events.
Huh?
You changed the fates of many people tonight.
The first of which was hers.
Lin?
We killed people in the process, too!
We killed other people!
If you had not been there for her tonight, her fate would have been...
would have been to die in that lonely spot on the outskirts of town.
The return of the best character of the game.
If that had occurred, what do you suppose would have happened?
I don't... I don't know.
Let me tell you a story.
The story of a little creature.
What?
After they stole her life that night, they broke into her apartment.
Oh!
Missile!
Don't hurt missile.
Don't do it.
Oh!
Don't do it!
It's not necessary!
They stole the wooden box from the ceiling hiding place and left.
How did they know it was up there?
And in the process...
They killed them both?
Two little dead bodies were left behind.
What?
However...
The little fellow's spirit lived on.
He desperately reached out his paw towards his mistress.
And that's when a miracle occurred.
What?
Look at that!
The powers of the dead!
But how?
He didn't really understand it himself.
Not yet, anyway.
With all you know now, I bet you understand it, do you not?
Hey, wait a minute.
Look at the toe as he shoots him.
Oh my god, why is it...
Oh!
Oh my god, because he was close to sis...
I mean...
Yeah, sis...
Wait, not sis...
Oh my god, my brain.
He died inside the aura of that strange energy.
But unfortunately, with his meager powers...
He was unable to save his little mistress.
Oh, there just wasn't anything he could do.
With only the power to swap objects.
He needed the power to manipulate objects in order to save the little lady.
The little fellow chased after the men.
There still wasn't anything he could do.
In the end, he was left behind with the man in red in the deep, deep sea.
Oh my god, no!
And then...
Okay...
He went back.
He went back to the world ten years before to the moment of the man in red's death.
Huh?
What?
He decided to wait it out.
He decided to wait until that night came again.
That's the other version of the story of this night.
Is this Missile?
He's been waiting this whole time?
Oh my god, Hihachiko!
He...
A story that has taken these ten years to be retold.
So that was you.
Old Soul!
That's right.
I'm Missile.
Hold on, he needs like a really...
What?
No way!
I'm Missile.
Ten years is a very long time in dark years.
You couldn't change the fates of these people on your own.
Wait, but how did he go back in time?
That's why he had the grandpa voice.
Oh my god, you're right!
So you decided to wait those ten years out.
Best character.
Missile.
Exactly.
And then at last, that fateful night rolled around again.
Punished Old Missile.
Old Missile.
Oh my god.
But this time I had grown old and my powers were weak.
So I decided I needed to find somebody to help me this time around.
That's why he lied about the dawn, right?
Just because everything had to be done tonight.
Somebody who possessed different powers than me.
But wait a second.
You were able to manipulate that desk lamp.
Over the course of the long years, my powers changed.
My ability to swap objects weakened.
But I became able to manipulate small objects.
But in that case, why didn't you cooperate with yourself?
Because I couldn't.
Ten years and the joint made you an MGS pirate.
Huh?
From watching the man in red, I found out there were individual differences in our powers.
I couldn't do any of the things he could do.
Like travel through the telephone lines, for example.
What?
It may not seem like much, but it's a very important power.
Especially if you're trying to chase somebody.
But there's something I don't understand.
You knew from the very beginning that I had that power.
How did you know so much about me?
Why wouldn't I?
After all, we had met before on that night the first time around.
We what?
We met before?
From listening to the conversation of the two intruders to the apartment, I learned that Ms. Lin had lost her life at that junkyard on the edge of town.
I followed the ghost world path to the junkyard and came upon an incredible scene.
Imagine, if you will, there in the darkness a twisting and swiveling desk lamp.
It made my first and on end, I can tell you.
That was me?
So I was shot on that night the first time around as well.
You had lost your memory that time too.
You had just died and you felt confused.
You declined to cooperate...
You declined to cooperate with me.
I did what?
I just want to find my own lost memory.
I'm sorry, but I can't help you.
Wait, but that happened too.
That's what you said.
And then you disappeared.
Oh, way over the telephone line.
I'm really sorry I didn't help you.
That's why I decided that this time I would use that desire of yours to our mutual advantage.
Mutual advantage?
The only thing you were interested in was finding your own lost memory.
If I could guide you along the right path to doing that, we would both benefit.
And namely, the right path would be...
The path to the man in red.
To Yomiel.
What?
I gave you the information you needed to know to set you in the right direction.
And then I gave you a time limit.
A time limit?
That's right.
As you know, I said you only had until tomorrow morning.
If I hadn't done that, you wouldn't have found out the truth tonight.
And the man in red would have been sealed away at the bottom.
At the bottom of the sea forever.
If that had happened, it would have been all over.
Smart doggo.
Then you mean...
That thing about ceasing to exist?
Oh, that?
Completely made up.
A little naughty of me, I know.
But I just wanted you to use your time wisely.
I really thought that the lamp was the wife.
Oh boy.
I hate to admit it, but this little doggie really outsmarted me in every way.
Let's just call it the wisdom that comes with it.
I didn't expect a missile.
Old missile.
And now it's time to say farewell.
These past ten years will cease to exist, and with them, so will I.
But you'll be regular missile.
You can rest now, old missile.
I believed in you.
I always knew you could do it.
And so you did.
Thank you.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart.
Why do you keep timing it like this?
That's so plain, it's like a damn poodle.
So you waited and waited these ten long years.
All for the sake of your two ladies, Lynn and Camilla, eh?
Of course.
That's because that's what doggies do!
Now then, farewell, sissel.
And so the story of a single night came to an end.
And only a single night that for us spanned across several weeks.
Oh!
Oh no, I can't even read it!
I made my way back, back to a new present!
I didn't, I thought it was, I thought it was push to, push to proceed.
Missile best boy waited twenty years to help his masters.
Bestest boy ever.
Thank you, thank you!
Chuu!
How come it's dark?
This is not push also, so...
I'll just turn on the lights here.
Oh!
Oh my god.
There's no gun!
Hehe, were you surprised?
You bet I was, you nearly scared me to death!
Don't joke like that, Lynn.
Yippee!
It worked!
It's not even my birthday today.
It was my mom's birthday the day before yesterday.
I made this surprise for her, but it came out so well, I want to use it again.
Do we get to see the mom?
That's alright, Lynn.
After all, we're celebrating the birth of your new position as detective, right?
Really?
Thank you, detective child.
Daddy, you're home!
Hi, Camilla.
Let me introduce you.
This is Lynn.
She was just assigned to the detective...
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d...
The-the-the... The-the-the...
The Detective Division today.
Hi, Camilla.
It's nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too, Lynn.
Congratulations on becoming a detective.
Wait, so... but he should remember this, right?
I guess the two of them don't remember?
Huh?
There's something wrong?
Yeah, one of those badges too!
Oh, this?
Yeah!
I have one just like it!
My dad gave it to me the other day.
But yours looks a lot older than mine.
How long are you going to keep wearing that toy badge, Lin?
Oh!
What's wrong with it?
To me, this is the symbol of a real detective!
It's been 10 years since then, hasn't it?
Who would have guessed you'd actually become a detective one day?
When he gave me this badge, I just knew.
I knew it was my destiny somehow.
Destiny, eh?
And now that I'm a detective...
I'll find out where that destiny will lead me!
So they don't remember, but...
Um...
Yomiel...
Sissel...
Missel...
And...
Jao would remember.
Haha, that you will.
That you will.
Nyaa!
Sissel!
Don't tell me you're the same little kitten.
That's right, the very one.
You know what?
This is a very, very special cat.
He's 10 years old, but he's still a kitten!
Still a kitten?
Yep, he never got any bigger or anything!
Huh?
Was he... does he have the...
Was he struck with the...
With the fragment?
What a mysterious little fellow!
I know, right?
His name is Sissel!
Sissel.
Seems to me I've heard that name somewhere before.
Really?
How mysterious.
I think Sissel likes you, Lin.
Like Motomo...
Mom!
Oh my god.
Alright, everyone.
Let's start the celebration!
Okay, mom!
Sissel is so cute!
I bet you're just like me.
Your destiny led you here somehow, too.
I'm so glad everybody lived.
And so we meet again, Sissel.
Yay!
From just that single night as a human, I got a glimpse into their world.
And I learned something.
Wait, where's Missel?
Where's Missel?
Their fates, their lives, they were all interconnected.
Somewhere, somehow, in some way.
Where's Missel?
And now, this is my new fate.
I'm a ghost cat.
Oh my god, she...
Look at that spaghetti!
That's the best plate ever!
I guess I really am a cat.
It suits me just fine to curl up and watch...
Oh, it's too fast!
And it looks like I have plenty to watch here for quite a while.
Where is Missel?
I was too distracted by the spaghetti to read the text.
Like I said, it isn't my birthday.
Oh my god, Missel!
Hey, Missel.
I thought I asked you to stay home and guard the fort.
The birthdays are for celebrating together with friends and loved ones.
Nothing like it, baby.
Oh, he's eating the spaghetti!
The best detective eats the best meal.
Oh my god, look at Mataro just sitting there with her wine.
No way.
Look at this wannabe!
Look at this!
You don't even have half...
Your pinky toe doesn't even have a fraction of his smoothness.
Definitely not good.
Maybe now I can be a great detective just like Inspector Cabanela.
What kind of example is the inspector providing for his men?
Such a great game.
Oh, his toes are out even at the bar!
Oh my goodness gracious.
Here's your food, gentlemen.
She's still looking for someone...
Ew, the toes!
Oh my god.
Memory, what are you doing here?
I heard you were going to be picking some new members for the Special Investigation Unit today.
So you took on a part-time job here again just so you could eavesdrop?
I forgot about this.
I forgot about it again.
Oh, you have no idea the lengths I'd go to reach my goals.
Thanks for the awesome playthrough.
I've never cooked this way before.
Blah, blah, blah.
Tumeric, coriander, cumin and...
Is this really necessary?
This new curry chicken?
Very best customer requested it.
What about the other country?
I guess they're not interested because...
There was never...
I don't think I could eat another bite.
Just who exactly is this very best customer anyway?
Is it Missile?
Oh, it's this guy!
I really enjoyed your playthrough of Ghostrix.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
What was I going to say?
I guess the other country doesn't get involved because...
Oh, here they are!
Doing other activities.
Are you sure we really need all these explosives?
Not to worry, beauty my dear.
I follow the instructions exactly.
20 kilograms of gunpowder just like it said.
Oh my god, Shaggy is going to die here.
I can't wait to watch it.
Die, Shaggy, die!
Wait a minute.
20 kilograms?
I thought it was 20 grams.
Lucky day!
Wait, does that mean she also died?
Is this guy also about to die?
Death to Shaggy!
But my wife also died.
That's so sad.
So this is where you work, huh, papa?
Papa?
Why did I say it like that?
That's right, sweetheart.
Darling husband, don't you have any idea at all you could give me?
You must have heard some juicy stories.
The indiscretions of a minister.
No, no.
Must you talk that way in front of our darling angel?
Here's to the stodgy mind of my darling husband.
Oh!
So happy I got to watch this game with you.
Thank you!
So awesome!
Ashen, thank you!
Thanks for the spooky numbers!
Ransom beating one of my favorite games of all time.
So good.
I don't think the game needs a sequel.
Hoping that potential sequel comes alive.
This deal is going quite well.
Oh, I must say, these grapes are quite good.
The young Genoa is about to scrape the bottom of the sea, sir.
Oh!
Eek!
God!
Keep it together, man.
Are you trying to give me a case of the vapors?
I believe I nearly died of fright just now.
Dead blue lady can be your ghost wife now, though.
Ghost wife!
Oh, it's this guy.
Yeah, rock and roll!
Love, peace and pigeons!
Long live rock and roll!
Oh, he's gonna go check it out.
One of my favorite games ever.
It's so awesome!
I can see why some people said it's their favorite game.
Or one of them.
I love pigeon man.
Oh!
Pigeons joining on!
Pigeons rock it out!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Stop the poor from...
Oh!
I didn't get to read it.
Yeah!
They didn't bother changing his prison outfit.
I guess that's fine.
They planned a Ghost Trek 2 where Phoenix Wright dies?
That'd be awesome.
Today's the day, you know?
It's finally getting out.
Oh, he's doing the panic dance.
You know, everybody's starting to get real tired of seeing you do that.
Now let me show you a new dance that's been passed down in our family!
Oh!
We do this when we have a stomach ache!
We call it Dance Away the Pain!
Oh, I'm real interested in that one.
Think you could show it to me next...
Say, next week?
You got it!
I love the prison guards!
Bailey!
Yeah!
This game has such fun characters.
Oh, he's getting out!
Ten young long years, yo-meow!
Your time's up today.
The young lady who always comes to visit you is waiting outside.
Oh my god, wait, what was the painting?
Thank you, Cecil.
What's the painting?
He has working legs.
I was thinking that too.
I was wondering if he would like...
if his legs would...
Oh!
Wow!
Cecil!
The painting!
Oh!
Cute!
Oh my god, what a good...
Good babies!
Is he gonna show up in the picture too?
Oh!
No!
I always wanted to see you play this game.
It's been such a fun watch.
Thank you, Red!
Thank you!
So cute!
Oh my goodness!
The mom took the photo.
Oh, yeah, I guess that makes sense.
I mean, she wasn't in the game like 99% of it, so...
Oh my gosh!
I wanna go hug my pets now.
I wanna go hug Pies and Butaro.
I wanna go hug them.
I wanna...
Especially because Cecil looks so much like Pies.
I thought it might take about six hours to beat and we're a little under that, so...
Nice!
Thank you for playing my favorite game of all time.
Thank you!
Go hug them.
I will after...
Oh!
Is that a doughnut?
There we go.
Oh!
There's the rat!
Get that rat!
There are so many rats in this game.
Congrats on the completion of one of my faves.
I love how despite all the craziness, everything somehow gets explained in the end.
Also, make sure you subscribe to my channel.
Missile the best.
Yeah!
Missile the best!
Thanks for the pink bikini!
Thanks for such a fun playthrough of such a great game.
That was so awesome!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so glad that I played it.
Oh my god!
I'm so glad I played it.
That's so good.
This is good, isn't it?
Oh, Missile.
I can't believe the lamp was Missile all along.
Waiting...
10 years.
Missile.
That's crazy!
Waiting the 10 years for the whole thing to happen over again.
Oh my god.
No!
It was so good.
Missile is the best boy.
Missile.
Look at you.
Look at the Capcom logo.
Oh, I like the picture of the meteor.
It's so pretty.
This is my first time experiencing this game.
Doing it alongside you.
Your voice acting was an absolute treat.
Sorry.
My voice acting maybe was a little...
inconsistent, but...
It was still fun to do.
Really looking forward...
Really looked forward to them these past few weeks.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
Cecil background!
So cute!
Reincarnation.
I noticed that there was like, ghost puzzles.
Like, um...
There was like some...
Oh, the challenges.
Right?
There was like, some other challenges towards the end.
That was like, solve...
Oh!
You did it!
So we got one!
Too much medicine.
Take aim and nail it on the second try.
Fail by keeping the ball away from Mino.
We got this one, too.
Fail by removing a large symbol.
Clear all challenges.
Complete...
This!
The 5x5 Ghost Puzzles.
What are these?
Ghost Puzzle.
Lin's apartment?
Oh!
Oh no!
No, no.
Get me out of here.
We'll be here for the next 5 hours.
He technically waited 20 years.
The cat left him the first time.
That's right!
You're right!
It's a tile puzzle.
Oh gosh, okay.
Thanks for the great streams, Minto.
Thank you too!
Thank you!
It's cool though that the puzzle is moving.
That's so fun.
Oh wow!
Look at him go!
My brain is... actually this feels... makes it so much more difficult.
How am I supposed to know what's in the middle?
Because they're all moving.
Right?
Wait.
How am I supposed to know?
Oh it's... oh my god.
This is so... what?
You like slide puzzles, Mint?
Actually, I can't say that I'm a fan.
Okay!
We can see... you know what?
That's good enough for me.
That looks good enough for me.
We can see a third of it, you know?
There we go!
Look at that!
It's so yummy!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you.
What if I do a hint?
Oh!
Okay, it says which one is what.
Okay, okay.
Wait, so... oh, my five and eight are mixed up.
Oh, well, I think I already knew that actually.
Anyway.
Okay.
I don't want to be here all night because I'm stupid.
Memories?
All these fun characters.
Oh!
Beloved mother.
The other me.
Why... why doesn't the top text change?
But the bottom text changes.
That's weird.
Also...
Where is Sissel?
Did I just miss him?
Oh, gosh.
It's...
Who is this?
Oh, that's the fastidious glass polisher.
Black hearted blue woman.
It changes over the course of the game.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
Missile has seven pages.
Friendly little Pomeranian.
His name is Missile.
Thinking he needs his powers to protect the little lady, he chose not to be brought back to life.
He went back in time ten years with me to help fight the last battle against fate.
Me.
The mystery.
I lost my life at a lonely spot in the outskirts of town.
My name is Sissel.
Oh, that's the secret.
I learned it from the Oh, I see how it changes.
Like, is that me?
Oh, okay.
It's not me!
Oh, and then he turns into a wisp.
But it doesn't show him as the cat.
It's interesting.
Hm.
Hmm.
Illustrations...
Oh!
Wait, this is so cool!
Wait...
Missile was almost not a Pomeranian!
Missile was almost a Bulldog!
Blue-haired Camilla, blue-haired Camilla, blue-haired short-haired, blue-short-haired Camilla, blue-short-haired Camilla...
Blue-short-haired Camilla, blue-short-haired Camilla, come back to me, blue-short-haired Camilla!
Oh my god, baby Camilla!
Little baby!
Yeah!
Wait, this one's so awesome!
Actually, they're all awesome.
Whoops, sorry.
Goatee!
Goatee Sissel.
Oh, this one's so cute!
It's like a traditional detective.
This one...
What in the totally spies am I looking at?
Wow, such designs!
No, I like Lin the way she is now.
Oh, this middle one's cute!
Oh my god, this middle one is so...
Oh my gosh, what's her name?
From...
From Apollo Justice.
Very...
It's the goggles, it's the goggles.
Oh wow, she looks so different.
No, I like the design that they went with, though.
Who the hell is this?
Who is this?
Is this the daughter?
Huh?
I like the melon-pon in her head.
What?
Who is this?
I was just thinking totally spies.
Who are you?
Who are these people?
Gumshoe?
Emma Sky, thank you.
I think chat's a little delayed.
Sorry, guys.
Oh my god!
Not a thought behind those eyes.
Also, looks like in this picture...
She's got cow udders.
Oh my god, beaver!
Camilla again, maybe.
Oh, these are so fun!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Oh my gosh, so...
Oh my god, my eyes.
So bright.
Wow!
Oh my god, they're storyboarding for...
Everything!
Wow!
What is going on here?
Oh my god, that's so cute!
That's so funny.
It's what goes on behind the scenes when the camera stops rolling.
Oh, there's even more if I complete the puzzles!
Okay, maybe I have to complete the puzzles then.
Wow!
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the spooky number!
Because I'm a star!
Stellar, stellar!
As a proud black cat owner, I'm glad Sissel got a happy ending.
Congrats on beating the game.
It's been such a wild ride.
Thank you!
Yeah, I...
I'm really glad.
I was really worried that...
I was really worried.
I mean, I guess we technically lost Old Missile.
You know, not everybody made it.
But Old Missile also...
Old Missile needed to rest, you know?
So awesome.
Old Missile needed to rest.
Ghost trick.
Oh, that's literally what we were listening to.
I like how there's a range and then the original.
Changing fate.
Yeah!
Did I hear this one?
No.
We'll put on the happy one.
I'm so sleepy!
I think I'm gonna go now, guys.
Thank you for watching until the very end.
Thank you for...
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
I hope you guys enjoyed the ride just as much as I did.
And...
It was so fun.
Oh my gosh, I just realized it's so behind.
Maybe.
I'm gonna go get some rest now and I suggest you all do the same as well.
Thank you guys for this fun adventure.
Get some rest.
I'm gonna...
Actually, I'm gonna finish my dinner, too, even though it's so late.
I'm gonna finish my dinner.
I'm gonna go get some rest.
Atsumito, everybody!
Thank you for letting me play Ghost Trick.
It was so fun.
And...
Oh my gosh.
I think my head hurts now from crying.
So...
I gotta get some...
Hold on.
I have some tea here.
I hope you guys liked it as much as I did.
Gosh, I love stories like this.
Oh, I love time travel.
I love time travel.
Let's see.
Tomorrow, I will be playing Minecraft in the V-Shojo server with Hennya and Iron Mouse.
So...
And...
It will be starting at 8 PM EST.
Sorry again about no schedule up yet.
Just...
I don't know if I'll be able to do one this week, honestly.
But...
I'll have one up next week, as well, even though it's also a short week, because next week, I'll have...
I'll be going to Off-Kai!
So...
I will be there.
And...
I'll...
Yeah.
If you're going to Off-Kai, I'll see you soon, maybe!
And...
Then, right after that, I'll be going to Japan.
So...
Schedule for that, when I'm in Japan, will also probably be...
I'll make a graphic for it that says, like, what's going on.
So you guys don't see, like, the same old schedule that's up.
But...
I'll have a schedule for next week, at least.
At the very least.
I'm a sucker for time travel.
Me too!
Me too.
Oh...
That was very good.
Loved your gameplay and commentary.
Thank you!
Some of the...
Some of the puzzles really did stump me.
But I feel I did alright with some of them, as well.
So...
Okay, guys.
Get some rest.
I'm going to...
Sleep.
Okay.
See you guys!
See you, see you, see you!
And I will see you...
Tomorrow, maybe.
If not tomorrow...
Friday?
If not Friday?
I'm not streaming Saturday?
If not Saturday, Sunday?
Wait, I mean...
But I'm at...
The...
At...
Parking.
Parking lot on Saturday?
If not Saturday, Sunday?
If not Sunday, Monday?
If not Monday, Tuesday?
If not Tuesday, Wednesday?
Okay!
Bye bye!
Thank you everybody!
See you!
Have a good night!
Bye bye!
Oh my gosh.
I forgot to mention, too.
For people that are...
That are Patreon people...
I'm going to be doing a watch-along this week, as well.
So...
So I'm planning to...
I'm going to be doing a watch-along this week, as well.
I'm not sure what time.
I might do it like Sunday afternoon and then stream Sunday night.
So, double me for that day maybe.
So, yes.
We'll be watching a movie together.
Okay, just wanted to say that too.
That's good to know about all the little clips.